Zu den Menschen zu gehören, die ihre besten Kräfte der Betrachtung und der Forschung objektiver, nicht zeitgebundener Dinge widmen dürfen und können, bedeutet eine besondere Gnade. Wie froh und dankbar bin ich, dass ich dieser Gnade teilhaftig geworden bin, die weitgehend vom persönlichen Schicksal und vom Verhalten der Nebenmenschen unabhängig macht. Aber diese Unabhängigkeit darf uns nicht blind machen gegen die Erkenntnisse der Pflichten, die uns unaufhörlich an die frühere, gegenwärtige und zukünftige Menschheit bist.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 59. Es ist wieder soweit eine kleine Gesprächsrunde über interessante Themen. Und ja, wir haben den 15. Dezember 2007 mein Name Tim Pritlove am Apparat und mein Gast heute zu einem sehr weltbewegenden Thema ist Sandro, Sandro Gaycken. Unser Thema soll heute sein Überwachung und zwar ausnahmsweise mal nicht Überwachung mit Videoüberwachung, mit Datennetzen, wie wir es hier und an anderen Stellen schon häufiger gehabt haben, sondern es geht eigentlich um die Überwachung als solche. Anders der ganzen Geschichte ist, dass du zusammen mit Constanze Kurz, die ja auch gerade auch im letzten Chaosradio Podcast schon wieder vertreten war, Sprecherin ist beim CCC, dass ihr zusammen ein Buch herausgebt, gegeben habt, das ist jetzt erschienen, richtig?
Das ist jetzt nächste Woche gekommen, die ersten Exemplare.
Okay, also für die meisten, wenn sie es hören, ist es schon soweit. Genau. Okay, also das Buch ist fertig und wartet jetzt eigentlich nur noch da drauf, dass die Lastwagen losfahren. Harry Potter aus den Regalen verdrängen. Das Buch heißt 1984.exe und befasst sich mit Überwachung im Besonderen und im Allgemeinen. Vielleicht, bevor wir auf das Buch und vor allem jetzt auf die Sachen mit Überwachung eingehen, kannst du vielleicht mal kurz ein bisschen was zu deinem Hintergrund sagen. Du bist ja wissenschaftlich tätig, auf vielfältige Art und Weise und hast einen Schwerpunkt auf Technik, Philosophie. Kann man das so zusammenfassen?
Ja, kann man so.
Kannst du gerne vielleicht was blumiger ausschmücken?
Nein, ich arbeite eigentlich im total unblumigen Bereich, mache Wissenschafts- und Technikforschung. Ich habe jetzt auch gerade promoviert, bin jetzt promovierter, also so gut wie promovierter Wissenschafts- und Technikforscher. Ich bin halt als Philosoph in der Wissenschafts- und Technikforschung, das ist also eine interdisziplinäre Disziplin, wo Soziologen, Historiker, Philosophen so ein bisschen zusammen rumforschen. Und ich habe halt viel Wissenschaftsphilosophie gemacht, Wissenschaftstheorie und bin jetzt halt in den letzten zwei Jahren durch meine Promotion, die gegenüber technisches Wissen, das ist so ein bisschen auf der Schneise zwischen Wissenschaftstheorie und Technikphilosophie, bin ich halt ein bisschen näher an die Technikphilosophie reingekommen und dadurch, dass ich ja auch schon lange beim Club assoziiert bin, so ein bisschen, habe ich mich natürlich auch für die politischen Themen interessiert und mich so ein bisschen in die praktische Technikphilosophie eingelesen. Und jetzt fahre ich so zweigleisig, Wissenschaftstheorie und Technikphilosophie und bin jetzt ab dem, ab Januar an der Uni in Stuttgart engagiert, in dem Bereich auch.
Du musst ja nochmal nachhaken, also Technikphilosophie, das ist so ein Begriff, meine Philosophie, da habe ich dann immer gleich irgendwie so Leute in Tonnen, die irgendwie im langen Bad da so vor sich hin sind, die über die Welt...
Der hat übrigens auch immer auf dem Marktplatz onlineiert.
Ach wirklich?
Ja, das ist ein ganz notorischer, also, naja, ich sag das echt.
Aber das machst du nicht?
Nee, nee, ich halte mich zurück.
Aber es ist schon so auch so ein Philosoph gewesen.
Na ja, es ist ein Philosoph gewesen, aber man kann jetzt so den Bogen nicht schlagen, also das, was wir jetzt eigentlich aktuell gegenwärtig machen, dass die Damen, die antiken Philosophen, haben sich ja sehr noch mit Lebensfragen, mit der Welt, dem Universum, also, wie heißt das bei Douglas noch, das Universum?
Das Leben des Universum und dem ganzen Rest.
Genau, ja. Damit haben die sich hauptsächlich beschäftigt. Und das war natürlich, allerdings ist jetzt auch halt zweieinhalbtausend Jahre her, und seitdem haben wir einiges an Spezialisierungen durchgemacht. Es gab dann noch so die Flaute im Mittelalter, wo es dann auch wieder zurückging ins Mittelalter halt.
Wo man sich wieder mehr mit Keulen auf Köpfe mitbaut.
Ja, mehr mit Keulen und Gott und so. Aber seitdem hatten wir natürlich ganz erheblich Anteil auch an der Verwissenschaftlichung und sind selber auch sehr verwissenschaftlich geworden. Und jetzt die gegenwärtige Wissenschaftstheorie und Technikphilosophie sind natürlich sehr rigide wissenschaftliche Disziplinen. Da wird also sozusagen nicht philosophisch rumgeschwadroniert, was denn sein könnte und die Welt und so weiter, sondern da wird halt sehr genau nach sehr genauen Theorien auch gefragt, was denn Wissenschaft ist. Also jetzt die beiden Bereiche gehören eigentlich nicht so eng zusammen. Man packt das immer so zusammen, weil man immer dachte, damals Wissenschaft und Technik ist irgendwie so ähnlich und deswegen ist es auch immer noch irgendwie so traditionell zusammen. Aber es sind eigentlich relativ getrennte Fragestellungen jetzt geworden. Und so Wissenschaftstheorie zum Beispiel fragt man halt, was sind wissenschaftliche Methoden? Also wie wird wissenschaftliches Wissen generiert eigentlich? Und wie produzieren wir Wissen? Woher wissen wir das Wissen auch? Wie kann man es messen? Ja, messen ist mehr so die Frage, was sagt die Messung aus über das Wissen? Also kann ich sozusagen eine Theorie aufstelle und ich kann dann messen, dass die Theorie zu einem Grad stimmt, beschreibt es dann irgendeine Wirklichkeit in der Welt? Ist die Welt dann wirklich so, wie meine Theorie das sagt? Das sind interessante philosophische Fragen. Da gibt es jetzt auch so eine Verbindung zu Diogenes auf eine Art, weil die alten Philosophen damals sich alles Mögliche ausgedacht und dann die Philosophen in der Neuzeit sind dann auf die Idee gekommen, naja, man kann ja heute A und morgen das Gegenteil behaupten in der Philosophie, ja, man hat praktisch alle Macht, da muss man vielleicht dann mal einen Schritt zurückgehen, mal überlegen, was denn wissend überhaupt ist, wie kommt man überhaupt zu gesichertem Wissen? Also quasi so die Reflektion des eigenen Handelns hat dann stattgefunden und das ist dann sozusagen gemündet in die Wissenschaftstheorie, die Beschäftigung mit diesem strengen wissenschaftlichen Wissen als Wissensgenehse. Also da ist so ein bisschen vielleicht die Verbindung zu Diogenes. Mit Technikphilosophie macht dann ganz andere Sachen. Das ist eigentlich so eine sehr genuine neue Disziplin. Ich war im 19. Jahrhundert, gab es schon die ersten Technikphilosophen. Friedrich Dessauer ist, glaube ich, einer der ersten gewesen. Der hat im 19. Jahrhundert gewirkt. Marx ist natürlich auch, hat sehr starke technische Anteile bei sich.
Ach, echt?
Kapitel 13 vom Kapital Großmaschinerie in der Industrie.
Du redest nicht nur darüber, du hast es gelesen.
Ich habe es mal gesehen. Nein, ich habe natürlich schon gelesen, aber bei uns ist es halt so, dadurch, dass man eine ganze Masse zu lesen hat, liest man natürlich nur ausdrucksweise. Also es ist nicht immer so, dass man alle Bücher von A bis Z gelesen hat. Aber ich weiß schon, wovon ich rede.
Gut. Ich wollte dich jetzt auch nicht in Frage stellen. Ich habe es nicht gelesen, um es gleich weiter zu schmeißen. Okay. Okay, also auch Marx.
Das sind aber dann halt andere Fragen in der Technikphilosophie. Da gibt es auch ein sehr breites Spektrum an möglichen Fragen. Technik ist ja auch ein sehr komplexes Phänomen, wenn man erst mal so rangeht. Man kann sich dann halt fragen, was ist Technik? Wie hängt es mit den Menschen zusammen? Wie ist die Menschheitsgeschichte mit der Technik verbunden? Und wie gehen wir mit Technik um? Wie nehmen wir Technik wahr? Wie funktioniert unser Wissen mit Technik? Das war jetzt mal eine Frage in der Doktorarbeit, die ich da jetzt geschrieben habe. Oder halt auch so politische Sachen sind natürlich auch immer sehr beliebt. Also sowieso diese ganze Überlegung, ob jetzt wir schon die Sklaven unserer Technik geworden sind. Das war ja im letzten Jahrhundert sehr populär durch die industrielle, maschinelle Massenvernichtung von Menschen im Zweiten Weltkrieg und dann auch danach durch die Atombombe, wo man sich dann schon fragen musste, haben unsere technischen Mittel jetzt uns überflügelt? Haben wir irgendwie eine technische Situation erreicht, die wir selbst nicht mehr meistern können und die Technik uns irgendwie überholt und beherrscht uns jetzt? Diese Technokratie-These zum Beispiel heißt die.
Ist das so ein abendländisches Phänomen? Oder wird das global geteilt? Weil ich weiß immer so, bei dem Bild, was du gerade geliefert hast, fällt natürlich auch ein bisschen so unser Verhältnis zu Robotern ein, was ja mal so davon geprägt ist, so Frankenstein und irgendwie andere Monster, die er dann mal geschaffen hat.
Diese ganzen schönen Parabellen spielen da natürlich eine Rolle. Also sowas wie Frankenstein und auch Golem, der ursprünglich die ganzen Frankenstein-Mythen ist, ja dieses also sprach Golem. Und es gibt eine ganze Menge Science-Fiction-Geschichten und auch sonst viele Literargewerke, auch schon Prometheus mit den Flügeln und so. Nee, Icarus mit den Flügeln, oder Prometheus, der dann das Feuer gestohlen hat und dafür bestraft wurde. Es sind alles so Parabellen über die Technik, was der Mensch mit der Technik gemacht hat, dass er sich über die Götter erhoben hat, dass er sich irgendwie Sachen angeeignet hat, die ihm eigentlich nicht zustehen und ob er sich vielleicht damit einen Bärendienst erwiesen hat. Das sind schon alles so.
Ja, die Japaner, wo ich jetzt bei den Robotern drauf hinaus wollte, die haben ja zum Beispiel zu Robotern eine ganz andere Einstellung. Für die ist das ja so Freund und Helfer und so weiter. Und wenn auch immer, dass die Medien darstellen, dann immer gleich so, ja, da wird der Oma irgendwie aus dem Bett geholfen. Andererseits haben sie natürlich auch so diese Godzilla-Fantasien und sind irgendwie komplett zerspült worden. Natürlich durch die beiden Atombomben-Explosionen und haben da sicherlich dann auch ihren eigenen Teil. Okay, aber ich will jetzt nicht so sehr abschweifen, weil wir schweifen ja eh schon ab. Aber was mir noch mal interessieren würde, Technikphilosophie, meine ich, so an wissenschaftliche Gruppen oder Forschungsfelder, wird ja dann auch mal so ein bisschen, da möchte man natürlich auch mal nachfragen, okay, was ist denn jetzt die Dienstleistung für den Rest der Wissenschaft? Also was fällt denn jetzt bei sowas wie Technikphilosophie heraus? Also bei Wissenschaftstheorie hast du es ja auch schon ein bisschen gesagt, dass man so Maßstäbe kriegt, dass man das irgendwie so in die Realität überführen kann. Was ist jetzt so die Dienstleistung der Technikphilosophie für uns?
Na ja, einmal ist natürlich Erkenntnisgewinn sowieso, dass man das Verhältnis, das wir zu Technik haben, anders reflektieren kann, ein bisschen bewusst werden kann. Also ich könnte dir jetzt aus der Technikphilosophie Sachen erzählen, die sozusagen dein Bewusstsein, Technik gegenüber ändern würden, wo du es dann ganz anders sehen und wahrnehmen kannst.
Mach doch mal, ändere doch mal mein Bewusstsein. Ist das jetzt so eine Hypnose-Session?
Nein, nein, nein. Nein, das geht jetzt so schnell nicht. Da kannst du ja mal in meine Vorlesung kommen oder sowas.
Ich dachte, wir können jetzt hier mal so...
Unser Verhältnis zu Technik ist halt tatsächlich, wenn man erst mal anfängt, drüber nahe zu denken, man denkt immer so, naja, gibt es da schon zu denken? Oder was soll ich mich da jetzt mit beschäftigen? Aber wenn man erst mal anfängt, drüber nachzudenken, dann ist das wirklich ein total interessantes Phänomen. Und je mehr man drüber nachdenkt, desto mehr wird einem bewusst, wie wenig man darüber endlich weiß, wie eng man und auf welche vielfältigen Weisen man mit Technik verbunden ist. Man ist ja wirklich sehr verbunden mit Technik.
Meinst du, das Gefühl, dass man, wenn Stromausfall ist...
Nein, das ist eben... Viele denken halt bei Technik nur an Strom und Laptop und Waschmaschinen oder so, aber wir haben halt auch die Kleidung, die wir anhaben, ist Technik, alle Nahrung ist letztlich ein technisches Produkt, technisch produziert und diese ganze Infrastruktur, durch die wir uns den ganzen Tag bewegen. Also in Deutschland insgesamt selbst, wenn du in die Natur gehst, ist es alles begradigt und technisch bearbeitet. Du kommst eigentlich überhaupt gar nicht mehr mit Wildheit in Verbindung. Da kommst du gar nicht mehr dran. Also wir sind sozusagen, leben in so einer völlig durchtechnisierten Welt und Umgebung.
Man nennt das aber Kulturlandschaft.
Na ja, wie die Bauern das ja noch immer nennen.
Aber das ist eigentlich alles Technik letztlich. Zumindest durch Technik.
Ja, es hat alles eine technische Komponente. Und wir interagieren halt sehr viel. Viele unserer zwischenmenschlichen Handlungen werden durch Technik vermittelt oder haben mit Technik zu tun. Unsere kulturellen Handlungen. So ein schönes Beispiel, ja. Aber auch zum Beispiel die gesamte Kultur hängt sich an bestimmten Technologien auf. Musik zum Beispiel ist ein technisches Phänomen. Besonders halt nur Acapella und sowas.
Also Musikinstrumente und natürlich auch elektronische Klangerzeugung.
Solche Sachen. Also es ist schon ein sehr breites Phänomen, wenn man so anfängt, drum nachzudenken. Und dann kommt man dazu ganz erstaunlichen Bewusstseinsveränderungen. Also das ist sicherlich so ein Punkt, dass wir ein bisschen Erkenntnisgewinn produzieren zum Umgang mit Technik. Das mündet dann natürlich auch gleich über in verantwortungsbewussten Umgang mit Technik halt eben gerade diese Problematik, Zweiter Weltkrieg, Atombomben, dass man irgendwie mal darüber nachdenkt, was das eigentlich bedeutet, was man so produziert an Technologien, was man eigentlich produzieren sollte, was man produzieren könnte, wie man vielleicht besser damit umgehen kann. Wir sehen es ja jetzt auch an der Klimakatastrophe. Wir haben es nicht im Griff. Es gibt in der Technikphilosophie unendlich viele Bezeichnungen dafür, was da jetzt schiefgelaufen ist. Die schönste finde ich von William Ockburn, ist ein relativ älterer Technikphilosoph. Er hat das als cultural lack bezeichnet, als kulturelle Verzögerung. Man produziert Technologien relativ schnell. Man braucht dann aber ein, zwei Generationen, um zu sehen, was daran wehtut und was nicht. Obwohl man es vorher schon hätte wissen können, aber hat keiner darüber nachgedacht. Wir machen das jetzt einfach mal. Wenn es wehtut, dann ist es Aua. Man überlegt dann mal neu.
Aber dann könnte es auch schon zu spät sein.
Dann könnte es auch schon zu spät sein. Gerade Klimakatastrophe ist ja eine schwierige Thematik, weil keiner weiß genau, wo das hinführt. Da wird sicherlich auch wieder große Kosten geben, so im Kollateralschäden. Aber da ist dann halt die Technikphilosophie z.B. bemüht, z.B. aus diesen allgemeinen Betrachtungen herauszuhalten, Bewusstsein zu schaffen dafür, dass wir uns den technischen Gegenständen auch bewusst zuwenden müssen. Dass wir die nicht einfach nur nehmen und benutzen dürfen und die neuesten Gadgets und einfach immer nur drauf losentwickeln und machen, sondern dass da viel dranhängt, dass viel auch unserer gesellschaftlichen Organisation damit zu tun hat, in was für einer Gesellschaft wir leben, was für ein Miteinander wir pflegen. Hängt auch viel von den technischen Möglichkeiten ab, die wir haben.
so auch Verantwortung, die da auch etwas erwächst?
Und es ist ganz viel Verantwortung. Und da ist dann halt z.B. so eine Initiative der Technikphilosophie, der ich mich halt eben auch sehr gerne verpflichtet fühle, halt auch aus so einem Wandel von Bewusstsein und Wandel von Erkenntnis dieses Verantwortungsgefühl für Technik zu produzieren. Also das, würde ich sagen, ist so ein Gewinn, den wir anbieten können der Gesellschaft oder gerne anbieten würden. Da gibt es dann jetzt auch neuere Disziplinen, wie die Technikfolgenabschätzung, ist jetzt gerade sehr hip, die halt sich dann, das ist ein bisschen so eine Fusion aus Soziologie und Philosophie und so ein bisschen empirisch, die sich damit beschäftigen, sich Einzeltechnologien vorknüpfen und dann halt versuchen, so ein bisschen Zukunftsprognosen zu machen, wie wird das die Gesellschaft verändern, wie wird die Technologie sich verändern und so ein bisschen versuchen, gerade diese Fusionen auch zu beleuchten und dann...
Dafür gibt es ja eine Technikfolgenabschätzung, gibt es ja sogar bei der Bundesregierung eine Gruppe, oder?
Ja, der Petermann hier in Berlin ist da, die haben so ein Büro bei der Bundesregierung.
Die haben so beratenden Charakter?
Ja, ab und zu stellen die mal Berichte vor und so was.
Aber die... Die arbeiten auch in dem Kontext so?
Die arbeiten im Kontext, die arbeiten halt auf Bestellungen des Bundestags. Also es muss quasi von den Abgeordneten bei denen ein Gutachten zu einer bestimmten technologischen Entwicklung bestellt werden und dann produzieren die das und tragen das dann da vor. Und das ist eigentlich also viel philosophische Arbeit. Der Chef ist Armin Gronwald, ein bekannter Philosoph. Und die produzieren dann quasi aus diesem so ein bisschen philosophischen Kontext heraus ihre Gutachten, wie sich Technologien entwickeln. Und das ist dann tatsächlich auch für die Abgeordneten bindend, das zu lesen. Also die haben das so als Pflichtlektüre dann auf dem Tisch liegen, ob sie das wollen oder nicht. Aber ist das dann noch eine andere Sache? Ist da keiner im Test danach?
Schade eigentlich. Eigentlich müsste man so drei, vier, fünf Key-Wörter in die wichtigsten Dokumente einbauen und wer die nicht sagen kann, der darf dann auch nicht abstimmen. Aber da werden wir leider nicht so ohne Weiteres hinkommen.
Zur Biometrie gab es halt schon mal eins.
Ja, richtig. Diese Biop-2-Studie.
Und andere Sachen haben sich dann mit Zukunft der Tourismusindustrie beschäftigt. Unterschiedliche Sachen.
Das heißt, Technik-Philosophie ist jetzt nicht irgendwie so ein Hobby von so ein paar durchgeknallten Wissenschaftlern. Sondern es ist in der Tat ein seriöses Feld, wo viel gearbeitet wird. Und wenn ich dich richtig verstehe, widmest du dem auch eine ganze Menge Bedeutung zu in der aktuellen Diskussion. Jetzt hat es ja schon Technik-Folgenabschätzung. Und vor allem auch, was ich gerade ganz interessant fand, diesem Cultural Lack, so diese Verzögerung der gesellschaftlichen Reaktion auf die Einführung von Technik, ist natürlich jetzt gerade bei der hohen Geschwindigkeit von neuen Technologien, die auf uns niederprasseln, ein generelles Problem, denke ich. Ich meine, auch Internet ist nicht verstanden. Es wird viel geschrien über die Nebeneffekt, die das jetzt schon so mit sich bringt. Und es wird einfach ganz klar noch eine Weile dauern, bis da überhaupt genug gesellschaftliches Knowledge da ist.
Viele Sachen kann man auch nicht so richtig voraussehen, wie die sich entwickeln.
Ähnlich verhält es sich natürlich auch mit der Überwachung. Da kommen wir gleich zu. Jetzt wollte ich aber nochmal kurz, du hast ja schon gesagt, du rotierst auch so ein wenig im Umfeld des Chaos Computer Clubs. Du hast auch schon ein paar Vorträge gehalten auf dem Kongress, ein paar wissenschaftliche Sachen zu Quantenmechanik, Quantenkryptographie, zuletzt auf dem Camp, auch mit Argumenten gegen Überwachung. Oder hast du auch einen anderen Vortrag gehalten über das Thema noch, Technik, Hacker, Ethik?
Die Gegenentwicklung war noch so mein Titel, das hat sich so ein bisschen mit Hacker-Ethik im Zusammenhang aus Technik-Ethik beschäftigt. Die Hacker-Ethik ist ja eigentlich keine Fachethik, also aus philosophischer Perspektive heraus ist das ja nicht so eine Ethik, die sozusagen aus einer ethischen Theorie heraus entwickelt ist, sondern mehr so eine Art moralischer Leitfaden für den Hacker. Also da kann man schon legitimer Hacker-Ethik zu bezeichnen. Aber ich wollte es heute ein bisschen mehr auf eine technikethische Perspektive versuchen zu bringen. Das habe ich da gemacht.
Was ist denn eine technikethische Perspektive? Hängt das jetzt ursächlich mit der Technikphilosophie zusammen?
Ja, naja, also Ethik ist ja eine Teildisziplin der Philosophie nach wie vor, eine sehr starke Teildisziplin, beschäftigt sich ja mit den Fragen, mit der Frage, was sollen wir tun? Wie handeln wir richtig? Wie handeln wir verantwortungsbewusst? Und da gibt es jetzt halt eben auch als neuere Ausgliedung, also die ganze Technikphilosophie ist ja jetzt noch nicht so alt, in so 100 Jahren wird das richtig eine Disziplin ist vielleicht. Und so eine Ausgliederung davon, die jetzt noch neuer ist, ist dann die Technik-Ethik und die beschäftigt sich halt dann mit dem verantwortungsbewussten Umgang mit Technik. Die ist jetzt auch noch nicht so sehr ausgereift. Da gibt es noch erst eine Reihe Versuche, wie man das vielleicht sich denken könnte, wie man das konzipieren kann und dann freie Alternativen. Aber es gibt halt so ein paar ethische Rundüberlegungen, von denen aus man so bestimmte technische Probleme, Einzelprobleme zumindest mal angehen kann und sich mal ansehen kann. Und da ist halt die Überwachungsthematik halt auch so ein zentraler Punkt. Ich habe mich ja in dem Vortrag dann auch am Beispiel von Überwachung aufgehalten eigentlich hauptsächlich, obwohl dann meine Schlüsse ein bisschen allgemeiner waren.
Gut, vielleicht sollten wir da nochmal ein bisschen auf das Buchprojekt eingehen. Das Ganze ist ja eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit. Also es ist ja mehr eine wissenschaftliche Publikation als jetzt sagen wir mal Yet Another Book, was so in die Regale kommt.
Ja, es ist schon eine wissenschaftliche Publikation. Wir haben auch tatsächlich ein sehr strenges wissenschaftliches Lektorat bekommen vom Verlag nochmal.
Welchem Verlag ist das erschienen?
Transkript.
Transkript Verlag.
Das ist so ein neuer, einer der neun größeren akademischen Verlieger. Sehr guter Verlag, bringt gute Bücher aus. Da sind wir in der Serie Science Studies jetzt. Die auch sehr seriöse fachwissenschaftliche Bücher produziert fallen aber so ein bisschen aus dem eigentlichen Transkript-Programm raus, weil wir, also weil ich halt in dem Konzept für den Band ganz strenge Vorgaben mir rausgedacht habe. Also mein Interesse mit dem Band war sowieso ein bisschen Aufklärung zu betreiben. Das war jetzt sozusagen kein Interesse, fachliches Interesse jetzt mal so meinen Fachkollegen Überwachung näher zu bringen, sondern einfach auch mal Aufklärung zu produzieren mit diesem Buch. Ich denke, dass das dringend nötig ist in dem Thema. Und deswegen habe ich halt die Vorgabe gemacht, dass es ein bisschen populärer ist, populär wissenschaftlicher. Da fällt es halt so ein bisschen aus diesem Transkriptprogramm. Es ist halt eine wissenschaftliche Publikation. Aber es gab halt strenge Vorgaben an alle Autoren, das verständlich zu erklären, jetzt nicht in Fachgeschwafel auszuschieben.
Also es ist eher von Wissenschaftlern, aber nicht unbedingt nur für Wissenschaftler.
Ja, nicht nur für. Also ich habe halt, es war ein bisschen schwierig, ich habe halt versucht, das so zweigleisig zu fahren, dass es für Wissenschaftler immer noch interessant ist, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Also schon, dass die Autoren neue Thesen produzieren, neue wissenschaftliche Einsichten produzieren, aber halt eben unter der Voraussetzung, dass sie es so verständlich erklären, dass es auch jeder lesen kann. Und dadurch, dass es uns tatsächlich auch ganz gut gelungen, dadurch, dass wir strenge Vorgaben gegeben haben und dass der Verlag das dann auch nochmal streng nachkorrigiert hat. Ich musste auch meinen eigenen Beitrag noch zweimal überarbeiten. Ich war zufrieden mit, die haben das wirklich sehr ernst genommen auch. Und jetzt ist auch tatsächlich ein sehr lesbarer und sehr interessanter, erkenntnisproduzierender Band rausgekommen.
Wie dick ist das? 330 Seiten?
303 Seiten haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, 309.
303 Seiten. Das ist schon eine dicke Schwarte. Aber das hast ja nicht alles du geschrieben. Und auch nicht alles Constanze, sondern ihr habt da euren Beitrag zugeleistet. Aber im Wesentlichen ging es darum, Experten zusammen zu tragen. Das Thema aufzuarbeiten. War das schwierig? Was musstest du da durchmarschieren, um da hinzukommen?
War das von vornherein klar, wer da schreiben soll? Mir war es relativ klar, welche Disziplinen ich ansprechen wollte. Welche Akteure ich in dem Band haben wollte. Ich kenne das Thema jetzt auch gut. Ich kenne das Thema sowohl als Wissenschaftler als auch als Aktivist. Ich habe daher Kontakt zur Politikpraxisseite, aber auch zu den Wissenschaftlern, die in dem Bereich arbeiten. Da konnte ich mir relativ schnell was zusammenstellen, was für verschiedene Perspektiven ich gerne in einem Band drin hätte, der dieses Phänomen Überwachung wirklich mal aus allen möglichen Blickwinkeln unter die Lupe nimmt. Das war so ein bisschen das Ziel des Bandes, dass man wirklich jetzt nicht sagt, wir machen jetzt nur philosophische Artikel dazu oder nur technikwissenschaftliche Artikel, sondern wir versuchen mal, alle Perspektiven, die es zu dieser Thematik gibt, zu versammeln, um überhaupt mal jemandem, der sich für das Thema interessiert, die Möglichkeit zu bieten, sich da mal umfassend zu informieren, wer sich überhaupt auf welche Weise damit beschäftigt. Und damit war dann das Konzept relativ schnell aufgestellt. Also ich habe dann so eine inhaltliche Gliederung, da können wir dann auch nochmal drüber sprechen, schnell gemacht. Und der zweite Schritt war dann halt, sich Constanze zu holen. Da habe ich mich dann halt relativ schnell mit Constanze zusammengefunden. Hab dann mit ihr das besprochen, weil ich halt für die Technikteile einfach nicht ausreichend kompetent bin. Für die anderen geisteswissenschaftlichen Sachen und so ist gut, aber...
Das heißt, das Buch ist eigentlich schon jetzt von seinem, von dem Herausgeber-Team her ganz klar ausgerichtet. Es gibt einfach eine klare technische Komponente. Also da wird auch über Details geredet. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es so eine, wie soll ich sagen, gesellschaftliche philosophische Auseinandersetzung.
Der Titel ist ja auch, der Untertitel ist Gesellschaftliche, politische und juristische Aspekte moderner Überwachungstechnologien. Also so eine relativ breite Sache, die jetzt trotzdem nicht so diffus verschwimmt, aber wirklich mal so alle Perspektiven, die wirklich unmittelbar wichtig sind für das Thema, auch vereinigt.
Das Buch ist, also wir wollen jetzt gar nicht so sehr über das Buch reden, aber ich finde das eine ganz gute, ganz interessante Perspektive, die ihr da aufgemacht habt. Das Buch ist ja also in vier große Teile aufgeteilt, in Technik, in die Praxis der Überwachung. Dann ist vom Phänomen der Überwachung die Rede und den Werten der Überwachung. Also die letzten beiden Teile überraschen mich. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, okay, so mit den ersten beiden hätte man im Prinzip das Thema schon abgreifen können. Was war denn da jetzt so die Motivation, so eine Gliederung zu wählen?
Na, das ist einfach so, also die Gliederung habe ich eigentlich aus meinen persönlichen Erfahrungen mit dem Thema gemacht. Die waren zweigleisig. Einmal war es die Erfahrung, dass Wissenschaftler relativ wenig über die Praxis wissen. Dann war es die Erfahrung des Aktivisten und auch die generelle Öffentlichkeit relativ wenig von diesen Gedankenwissen, die sich sonst Wissenschaftler eigentlich über das Thema machen, die auch sehr interessant sind und zu dieser Diskussion eigentlich sehr viel beitragen könnten. Und das sind so ein bisschen diese beiden Gleise, die sich da wiederfinden. Also der eine Gleis ist dann halt sozusagen, so ein bisschen die Praxis zu beleuchten, also die Technik wirklich erstmal zu erklären, dass man auch eine solide Grundlage hat an Kenntnissen, dass man nicht nur, okay, man hört Biometrie, man weiß so ungefähr Pi mal Daumen, was es ist, aber dass man wirklich solide erklärt bekommt, warum es sich dabei handelt, wie sich das in Zukunft entwickeln wird und was da alles so passiert ist und passieren wird. Das leistet halt dieser Technik-Teil.
Der so aus fünf Abschnitten besteht?
Aus fünf Abschnitten mit reger Beteiligung des Clubs auch.
Richtig, da sind drei Namen zu lesen, die im Club-Kontext auch immer wieder auftauchen. Keine Überraschung.
Ja, also der Club hat da auch für mich ganz klar Kernkompetenz in dem Technikbereich. Das wollte ich auch drin haben. Dann der zweite Bereich, Praxis der Überwachung. Das ist halt auch noch so ein bisschen, was man den Wissenschaftlern auch ein bisschen erzählen kann, wie denn Überwachung eigentlich praktisch aussieht. Da sind dann solche Leute dabei wie Polizisten, also der Vorsitzende der Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft ist da, Rainer Wendt, Kriminalisten, der Leiter des Max-Planck-Instituts für Kriminalologie ist dabei. Hans-Jörg Albrecht schreibt ein bisschen was über die praktischen, empirischen Untersuchungen, die eigentlich gemacht wurden, zu Kosten und Nutzen. Dann die Datenschutzbeauftragten, deren Stimme mal zu hören, wie überhaupt das Problembewusstsein bei Politikern ist. Das waren auch alles klare inhaltliche Vorgaben von mir, die Themen, die die bearbeiten sollten, sozusagen. Dann auch sehr schöne Daten, schreibt hier Alexander Dix, der Datenschutzbeauftragte in Berlin, so ein bisschen was wie seine Erfahrungen waren mit den Politikern, wie die das Thema wahrnehmen, ob die es überhaupt ernst nehmen und so. Natürlich schöne Geschichten und Zitate drin. Und dann noch ist da auch noch ein Artikel drin von einem bekannten Strafanwalt aus Hamburg, der so ein bisschen interessante Straffälle macht und der dann sozusagen jenseits der Ideologie der Polizisten aus der Praxis berichtet, was er so aus seiner Strafanwaltspraxis auch mit dicken Fischen kennt, was die eigentlich effektiv schon alles an Mitteln haben, die in keinem Bericht auftauchen und wie die damit umgehen, wie schnell die da bei der Hand sind mit solchen Sachen und sowas. Also ganz interessant. Und dann kommt halt, das ist dann sozusagen so ein bisschen die Grundlage, die man, wenn man diese beiden ersten Kapitel liest, dann hat man sozusagen einen Einblick in die Technik, wie das alles aussieht, wie das funktioniert, wie das es so gibt. Und dann hat man einen Einblick in die Praxis, wie das gehandhabt wird, was die Politiker für eine Einstellung dazu haben, was die Polizisten für eine Einstellung zu haben, wie vieles von welchen Überwachungsmaßnahmen gibt, wie das in der Vergangenheit war und so weiter. Hat also sozusagen einen soliden empirischen Einblick in diese ganze Geschichte, wie es wirklich ist. Und dann schließen sich daran halt diese beiden theoretischen Kapitel an, Phänomen der Überwachung und Werte der Überwachung, die dann halt an dem Phänomenkapitel so ein bisschen die allgemeinen gesellschaftlichen und politischen Umstände beleuchten, wie man Überwachung bewerten kann, wie man das sehen kann, in was für Kontexte man das einbetten kann, was für eine Konsequenzen das für Gesellschaft hat und für Politik und wie sich die Menschheit verändert überhaupt mit Überwachung, was für einen veränderten neuen Umgang gibt damit.
Gut, vielleicht kommen wir nochmal zu der eigentlichen Desenz. Du hast ja, ich hab's schon angedeutet, auf dem Camp einen Vortrag gehalten, Argumente gegen Überwachung. Jetzt haben wir es natürlich immer wieder mit diesen Phänomenen zu tun, ja Überwachung, tolle Sache, schafft ja alles mehr Sicherheit und der Einzelne antwortet dann einfach stupide mit seinem, ich hab ja nichts zu verbergen. Das ist sicherlich eins der Argumente, mit denen du dich da auseinandergesetzt hast. Was ist denn das eigentliche Problem? Jetzt mal so ganz naiv gefragt. Wir haben natürlich immer mehr Technologie und viele Leute betrachten das natürlich auch als eine große Verheißung. Ja, super, jetzt haben wir überall Kameras, jetzt wird irgendwie unsere gesamte Gemeinde überwacht und dann haben wir da vertrauenswürdige Leute, die schauen sich das an und wenn dann irgendwie der Bösewicht kommt, dann wird er in den Wind geschlagen und alles ist prima. Früher haben wir ja auch Wachtürme gehabt und große Kirchtürme, wo man sich drauf stellen konnte, um zu sehen, wenn der Feind ankam. Und so machen wir das jetzt auch noch im Kleinen. Alles ist super, klappe aus, Tagesschau ist vorbei, wir gehen ins Bett.
Was ist das Problem? In dem Buch gibt es eine ganze Menge Antworten auf die Frage, was das Problem ist. Es ist nicht so einfach, dass man sagen könnte, das Problem ist eins, zwei, drei, sondern es gibt eine ganze Menge Probleme. Im Kern kann man erst mal ein bisschen übergreifend sagen, dass Überwachungstechnik eine seriale Gefahr ist. Einfach auch in der Form, in der sie jetzt existiert. Eine sehr vielschichtige Gefahr hat viele verschiedene Implikationen, verschiedene Dimensionen, die man da bedenken muss. Und dass ihre Einführung im Verhältnis zu der realen Gefahr mit relativ hypothetischen oder abstrakten Gefahren begründet wird. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sehe, diese ganze Terrorismus-Rhetorik, Terrorkeule, dann ist es ja gerade in Deutschland eine abstrakte Sache. Die drohen uns zwar alle zwei Wochen mit dem großen beladenen Anschlag hier in Deutschland. Aber effektiv ist jetzt nichts passiert. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass irgendwie Großes passiert. Und im Zuge dieser ganzen Androhung werden dann aber halt unglaublich große Überwachungsmaßnahmen durchgepaukt. Und also das ist vielleicht so ein bisschen so das Grundproblem, dass man eigentlich so eine Rhetorik hat. Diese politische Rhetorik, die einem halt verkaufen will. Man hätte eine veränderte Sicherheitslage. Und man müsse jetzt von dieser veränderten Sicherheitslage aus ein wenig die Grundrechte einschränken, vielleicht möglicherweise ein bisschen, um dem entsprechend entgegenzukommen. Und die Argumente dagegen, gegen diese Überwachungstechnik, sind eigentlich dann relativ unbekannt. Da kommt dann halt dieses Ich-hab-nix-zu-verbergen zum Tragen.
Was sind denn die?
Die reale Situation, das ist so ein bisschen die Situation, die so in der Öffentlichkeit dasteht. Okay, wir haben eine veränderte Sicherheitslage. Na ja, ich hab nichts zu verbergen. Und na ja, das ist jetzt halt mal so.
Schlimmes Wort, oder? Veränderte Sicherheitslage.
Ja, da gibt es auch ganz viele schöne Rhetoriken in diesen ganzen Reden. Da das so ein bisschen diese öffentliche Wahrnehmung. Klar mag das keiner bespitzelt zu werden, gerade auch nach der DDR. Jetzt hat man ja eine ganze Menge Erfahrung mit Spitzellei und so. Aber das ist halt mehr so ein diffuses Unwohlsein, ohne dass man eigentlich so seinen Finger drauf zeigen könnte, was denn jetzt auch in der gegenwärtigen Situation schlecht daran ist, überwacht zu werden. Und da muss man halt diese Gegenargumente, von denen es ja eine ganze Menge gibt, ein bisschen mehr publik machen, damit sich diese Rhetorik umdreht.
Ja, leg doch mal los. Wir haben ja jetzt hier irgendwie Zuhörer. Was sind denn die wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse oder auch aus dem Buch heraus, ist ja egal. Was ist denn das Problem mit der Überwachung?
Das Grundproblem kann man eigentlich ganz einfach zusammenfassen. Das einzige, was Überwachung tut, also auch technische Überwachung, ist Kontrolle produzieren. Das ist sozusagen das einzige technische Potenzial, das Überwachung überhaupt hat. Also Überwachung produziert Kontrolle. Kontrolle allerdings ist jetzt das Gegenteil von Freiheit und Vertrauen. Kontrolle, wenn ich jemanden kontrolliere, dann nehme ich dem Freiheiten weg, weil ich dem nicht vertraue. Und Freiheit, aber Vertrauen ist eben auch die Grundlage von Rechtstaat und Demokratie. Das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen, wenn man es ein bisschen einfach sagt, diese Trias-Überwachung produziert Kontrolle. Kontrolle ist das Gegenteil von Freiheit. Und Freiheit ist eigentlich die Basis von Demokratie und Rechtsstaat. Und wenn man sich das mal ansieht, erst mal als gegenrhetorisch, dann spottet das natürlich diese Beschreibung der Innenminister, die dann sagen, wir müssen jetzt die Demokratie mit Überwachung verteidigen. Man will sozusagen die Demokratie mit etwas verteidigen, das die Demokratie unterwandert und abschafft.
Ich will nicht so abstrakt bleiben. Also wenn du sagst, Freiheit oder Vertrauen ist die Grundlage von Rechtsstaat und Demokratie, dann ist das jetzt auch ein bisschen unkonkret. Warum ist das so? Warum ist das die Grundlage?
Es gibt halt eine ganze Menge Dimensionen, die man da bedenken könnte. Eine konkrete ist zum Beispiel die Privatheit. Man muss halt irgendwie so seinen privaten Raum haben, in dem man sich unbeobachtet fühlt. Es gibt zum Beispiel diesen Beobachtereffekt, da habe ich auch schon mal drüber geredet. Wenn man weiß, dass man beobachtet wird, dann fällt man sich anders. Man fällt sich auch schon unbewusst, unterbewusst anders. Also ohne, dass man es eigentlich selber merkt. Man verhält sich mehr gegen oder mehr für die Sachen, die der Überwacher will. Das heißt, wenn immer man überwacht wird, das kann auch technisch sein, dass man einfach mit einer Kamera überwacht wird oder dass man weiß, irgendwo hier ist eine Kamera, dann verhält man sich instinktiv, intuitiv anders.
Das ist belegt.
Das ist belegt. Es gibt eine ganze Menge psychologische Studien zum Beobachtereffekt. Das ist vor allen Dingen auch ein frappierendes Problem in der Wissenschaft. Es gibt diese Probleme mit teilnehmender Beobachtung und nicht teilnehmender Beobachtung in der empirischen Sozialforschung. Zum Beispiel, wenn man Sachen über das Sozialleben oder über kulturelles Leben von Menschen beobachtet, ob man sich dann mit reinsetzt oder nicht, ob man versucht, unentdeckt zu bleiben, um die zu beobachten, wie sie sich wirklich unter einander verhalten, oder ob man sich reinsetzt. Da gibt es dann Unterschiede. Wenn man sich reinsetzt, dann verhalten die sich anders. Ganz einfach. Da gibt es eine ganze Menge Untersuchungen zu, weil es ein schwieriges Methodenproblem ist in ganz vielen empirischen Wissenschaften.
Also heißt es, es gibt viele Studien dazu, heißt das, dass es unumstritten ist in der Wissenschaft?
Das ist unumstritten, ja. Die Existenz des Beobachtereffekts ist auf jeden Fall unumstritten. Was halt schwierig ist, ist zu sehen, wie das jetzt technische Überwachung konkret auf das politische Verhalten von Bürgern einen Einfluss nimmt. Aber man kann halt schon davon ausgehen, dass in dem Moment, in dem der Staat überwacht, vertritt dieser Überwacher ja politische Werte, die politischen Werte des Staates. Und die sind dann sozusagen bei allen Entscheidungen, die man so trifft, wenn man weiß, dass man überwacht wird, präsent. Irgendwie als Kontrastfläche. Dadurch, dass man, man hat quasi den Staat immer im Zimmer und der hört einem zu, was man denkt. Und das ist dann natürlich eine sehr reale Gefahr und eine sehr reale Einschränkung.
Man hört einem zu, was man denkt?
Na ja, alles, was man sozusagen technisch denkt. Das ist ja jetzt gerade die neue Situation, die wir haben, die neue technische Situation mit Informations- und Kommunikationsmedien-Technologien. Dass man viele Teile seines geistigen, kommunikativen Lebens der Technik anvertraut, technisch medialisiert. Also bloggt, chattet, mailed, telefon, la la la. Das kann halt alles abgehört werden und alles beobachtet werden. Und von daher ist der Staat oder sind halt die verschiedenen Agenten, die die Überwachung, es gibt ja viele verschiedene Akteure, die Wirtschaft und so weiter, sind halt dann präsent in diesen geistigen Akten, in diesen geistigen Handlungen, die man da unternimmt. Und da ist dann halt ein ganz realer Eingriff in die geistige Freiheit, wenn man da halt diesen Beobachtereffekt mit einbezieht. Das ist so eine Sache, dieser psychologische Beobachtereffekt, dann gibt es halt eine ganze Menge anderer Geschichten, noch diese reale Produktion von Misstrauen, dass man einfach statt einer Vertrauensatmosphäre eine Misstrauenatmosphäre produziert. Und dann gibt es halt eine ganze Menge Gefahren, wenn Überwachungstechnik dann auch effektiv missbraucht wird. Da ist immer so einer meiner Kernargumente ein Problem mit Überwachungstechnik ist nämlich, dass man die einfach nicht davor schützen kann, dass dann der nächste Adolf Hitler die auch benutzt. Das geht einfach nicht, eine prinzipielle Unmöglichkeit. Und man sieht es auch jetzt sehr schön, dass sich eigentlich die Anwendungsbreite von Überwachungstechnik orientiert sich nicht an irgendwelchen technischen Möglichkeiten, die demokratisch vorgegeben sind oder rechtsstaatlich, sondern orientiert sich an der Weite der Definition des Begriffs Terrorist. Und das ist eine sehr variable Definition, die halt dem, der das Wort gerade in den Munden hat, wie der, der halt beliebig rauskommt.
Also das, was sozusagen diesem abstrakten, weniger abstrakten Begriff Terrorist unterstellt wird, was er alles tun könnte, das alles muss dem technisch begegnet werden. Meinst du das?
Nee, ich meine einfach, dass man, man darf überwachen, wer Terrorist ist. Also wenn jemand Terrorist ist, dann darf man den überwachen.
Ach so, dass er sozusagen diese Vogelfreiheit, die damit zu ist.
Ja, man kann diese komplette technischen Apparat auf den anwenden. Und wenn mir jetzt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen totalitäre Züge in meinem Charakter habe und ich sage, morgen, okay, die Schwulen, die passen mir nicht mehr, das sind jetzt Terroristen, man erfindet dann irgendwas, weiß ich, irgendwelche randständigen Organisationen, Japan zum Beispiel hat jetzt Greenpeace offiziell zu Terroristen erklärt.
Was?
Ja, wegen Walfang, weil die die Walfang-Flotte aufhalten, das sind jetzt offiziell Terroristen. Und die dürfte man dann halt in Japan zum Beispiel auch lückenlos überwachen. Und das zeigt halt, also was das eigentlich nur zeigt, ist das sozusagen, dass die sehr missbrauchbar ist. Sobald da jemand rankommt, der irgendwelche komischen Interessen hat, dann sagt der einfach, okay, ihr seid jetzt alle Terroristen, ich bin der einzige Gute hier im Staat, ich überwache euch jetzt alle und wenn mir nicht passt, wird er abgeknallt. Das ist sozusagen dann das, was dahintersteht. Das ist halt ein unglaubliches technisches Potenzial, um ganze Bevölkerung auf Knopfdruck zu kontrollieren. Man braucht natürlich immer noch so ein bisschen die Exekutive, aber eigentlich stehen wir jetzt alle schon unter Dauerspitzelung. Und wenn derjenige, der uns bespitzelt, jetzt mal nicht nur auf Kinderpornografen und Terroristen achtet, also so muslimische Fundamentalisten, sondern wenn dem in den Sinn kommt, er möchte jetzt auch gerne Links-Alternative und irgendwelche Öko-Leute oder Hacker-Umwelt-Aktivisten möchte er auch gerne überwachen, dann steht ihm nichts im Wege technisch. Und das ist halt ein Problem. Das ist halt sehr stark missbrauchbar, die Überwachungstechnik.
Also jetzt hatten wir, ich würde ganz gerne noch mal bei diesen Argumenten bleiben, also Freiheit, Vertrauen wird eingeschränkt, dadurch, dass eben Kontrolle entgegengesetzt wird.
Und das halt eben nicht nur auf so einer rhetorischen, sondern auch auf so einer realen Basis. Also Geist und Freiheit ist halt ein psychologisches Phänomen, dass ich mich halt nicht eingeschränkt fühle in meinen Werten und nicht beobachtet fühle, sondern so frei.
Das ist ja auch eine Konsens-Demokratie. Der Glaube, dass alles, was verboten ist, könnte jetzt qua Gesetzgebung verhindert werden, ist ja Quatsch. Der Großteil der verhinderten Straftaten wird einfach durch einen Konsens einer Friedlichkeit verhindert. Dadurch, dass Leute eben einfach diese Regeln auch akzeptieren und sich sozusagen auch gegenseitig vertrauen. Da würde ich jetzt mit diesem Bewusstsein durch die Straßen gehen, dass jede einzelne verbotene Straftat mir in den nächsten zehn Minuten passieren könnte. Was weiß ich, dass mir irgendjemand ersticht oder schießt, ausraubt, entführt, erpresst und so weiter. Es findet ja alles in der Regel nicht statt. Und mit diesem Grundvertrauen streich ich natürlich auch eine gewisse Friedlichkeit aus, die sich dann auf mein Umfeld auch auswirkt. Und das sorgt ja eigentlich für eine Sicherheit, die ja sowieso nur so eine gefühlte Geschichte ist. So empfinde ich das. Und dass dieses Misstrauen, was einem entgegenkommt, ich versuche jetzt nur mal so in meinen Worten nach auszudrücken, was du im Prinzip gesagt hast, vielleicht trifft das ja den Punkt. Das ist in dem Moment, wo mir jetzt jemand einfach misstraut und sagt, so wie du aussiehst, bist du ja einfach eine potenzielle Bedrohung irgendwie. Du kannst unser Staatsgefüge erschüttern, weil du bestimmt morgen anfängst, irgendwelchen Mercedes-Benz-Luft aus den Reifen zu lassen. So was hat man jetzt hier gerade in Berlin. Und dann denke ich mir dann halt so, wenn ihr mir nicht vertraut, dass ich im Gesamtkonsens der Gesellschaft lebe und eigentlich nichts Böses im Schilde führe, warum sollte ich mich dann noch an eure Regeln halten? Und dann werden die Leute eigentlich auch erst marginalisiert. Und wer dann halt in die Ecke getrieben wird, der beißt.
Ja, ich meine, da gibt es halt unterschiedliche Untersuchungen, wie so Menschen auf Repressionen dann reagieren, wenn die wirklich dauerhaft ist. Es war ganz interessant, ich hatte einen Vortrag gehört von einem Kanadier, der hat eigentlich so eine Parallele gezogen, von Überwachtenden zu Kindern von überbeschützenden Eltern. Da gab es irgendwie so Parallelen. Also da gibt es halt auch noch nicht viele Untersuchungen zu. Das ist so ein Problem. Aber eine Parallele konnte gezogen werden zu diesen Kindern von überbehütenden Eltern, die halt auch dauernd da sind und dauernd ihr Wertesystem präsent haben und auf jede Entscheidung Einfluss nehmen. Und bei denen ist es auch so, wenn die einfach präsent sind im Raum oder auch irgendwie drei Räume weiter, dann entscheiden sich die Kinder so, wie die Eltern das gerne möchten. Sie sind einfach auch nicht in der Lage, ihre eigenen Werte in einen Anschlag zu bringen oder ihre eigenen Entscheidungen zu produzieren, sondern die haben halt immer ihre Eltern im Hinterkopf und immer die mögliche Repression, die dann passiert, und dann setzen die das immer um. Und mit der Zeit entwickeln die halt zwei Charaktere. Das eine ist Resignation und das andere ist Rebellion. Das sind so die beiden Grundcharakterzüge, die dann rauskommen.
Also entweder oder oder beides in einem?
Entweder oder. Das sind so die beiden Charakterzüge, die dann dabei rauskommen. Ich weiß nicht, in welchem Verhältnis der Rebell zum Resignierten steht, aber...
Beides nicht sehr gesund.
Nee, beides nicht sehr gesund. Und der Kanadier meinte, durch diese Parallelen könnte eine überwachte Gesellschaft sich unterteilen in Rebellen und Resignierte. Beides ist orientiert am Wertesystem der Überwacher. Die Resignierten sind frustriert damit, die Rebellen rebellieren damit. Weder die Resignierten noch die Rebellen haben noch ihr eigenes Werteprogramm oder ihre eigenen Entscheidungen. Da gibt es nur Pro und Contra, das, was die Überwacher vorgeben, aber keine eigenen Geschichten mehr.
Das heißt, wir landen letztlich in einer Gesellschaft, in der entweder alle resignieren oder rebellieren?
Ja, teils, teils, ein paar rebellieren. Man hat es ja in der DDR gesehen. Das war ja ein Spitzelstaat, und da hat man ja gesehen, wie die Leute darauf reagieren.
Also die Resignation schien mir vorzuherrschen.
Ja, Resignation herrschte sicherlich vor. Rebellion war halt auch da, aber man wurde natürlich ganz schnell auch drakonisch bestraft.
Bis es da nicht mehr ging. In diesem dritten Teil des Buches, also nachdem Technik und Praxis erläutert wird, kann man eigentlich auch gleich noch mal drauf eingehen. Also über Technik wollte ich jetzt nicht so viel reden, weil das hatten wir jetzt hier bei Chaosradio auch schon häufig. Also es geht da so um technische Überwachung generell, Telefon abhören, Vorwärtsdaten-Speicherungen ist da ein Thema. Das hatten wir auch bei Chaosradio Express erst vor kurzem. Was ist denn hier unter die geschlossene Welt? Ach so, Videoüberwachung und Biometrie. Das ist da im Fokus. Und Praxis hat es ja schon gesagt. Vielleicht sagen wir das noch mal kurz. Es ist interessant, was hat denn die Polizei dazu zu sagen? Also was sagt denn dieser reine Wend im Kern zu? Das ist ja so die andere Seite. Die Polizei, das sind ja immer so Leute, die sind immer extrem im Fadenkreuz der Diskussion, sag ich mal, so ja, die Polizei überwacht uns. Aber das ist ja letztlich nicht unbedingt die, zumindest nicht im einlichen Sinne die Polizei, die überwacht. Sondern der Staat meldet eine Überwachungsinteresse an und die Polizei ist letzten Endes die, die es durchbringt. Was meint denn die Polizei dazu?
Also als Erstes muss man den reinen Wind ein bisschen in Schutz nehmen und loben. Das ist nämlich so ein bisschen in den Band der Einzige, der sich so wirklich auch für Überwachung begrenzt ausspricht. Da hat er sich natürlich auf dünnes Eis begeben, hat das wohl auch vorher wusste, hat trotzdem einen Beitrag geliefert. Ich habe natürlich auch bei Innenministerien reichlich angefragt, sehr höflich, sehr zeitig angefragt, auch bei Bundeskriminalämtern, Landeskriminalämter. Und sogar bei einem, der sich gegen Überwachung immer sehr kritisch stellt. Und da war aber der generelle Kanon, dass man da nicht dran teilhaben will und sich nicht diskutieren, der Diskussion stellen will. Ein schönes Zitat ist dann aus dem Chefsekretariat von BKA, Chef Zierke, da hieß es dann, man wolle sich in diesem Gesamtkontext nicht äußern. Das spricht er schon bende. Und dann gab es noch einen LKA-Leiter, der eigentlich gerne was gesagt hätte, aber dann gefürchtet hätte, dass es so verzögert wird von den zuständigen Stellen, dass er dann nicht mehr rechtzeitig dazu kommt. Also es ist auch nicht so gewünscht bei den höheren Stellen. Von daher also auf jeden Fall dickes Lob an Rainer Wendt, dass er sich da geäußert hat. Und die Position der Polizei ist natürlich auch jetzt, man kann jetzt gar nicht so sagen, es ist so, also aus meinem Eindruck, dass es so die Position der Polizei gibt. Da gibt es auch solche und solche. Und es gibt aber auch eine sehr reflektierte Position in der Polizei, die halt eben sagt, wir haben jetzt mit neuen Kriminalitätsformen zu tun, die halt eben auch technische Medien sehr substanziell nutzen. Das sind auch vor allen Dingen diese sogenannte Transaktionskriminalität.
Was sind fast das?
Zum Beispiel Internet, also Terrorismus, Organisation von Terrorismus über Internet oder halt Kinderpornografie oder halt auch die großen Verbrecher, die ihre Schiebegeschäfte machen, die nutzen halt auch viel elektronische Kommunikation. Dafür bietet es sich ja an. Und dem muss man natürlich auch irgendwie habhaft werden als Polizist. Da ist natürlich auch ein legitimes Ermittlungsinteresse. Und da haben dann die Polizisten das Bemühen, das so seriös wie möglich und so eng wie möglich im Kontext mit den erlaubten Rechten abzuziehen, dass sie das zu machen, dass sie dann auch das Vertrauen der Bevölkerung dafür haben, diese Mittel einsetzen zu können. Das ist so ein bisschen das Interesse der Polizisten, die das dann auch so ein bisschen stärker reflektieren und besser verantwortlicher damit umgehen. Das ist natürlich auch legitim und da geht es dann bei der Polizei halt eben viel darum, die Verhältnismäßigkeit dann auszuloten. Da muss man sich dann halt, wenn man sagt, ich brauche Überwachung, weil es diese Transaktionskriminalität gibt, weil ich die irgendwie in den Griff kriegen muss, haben wir auch ein Interesse daran, dass die auch gefasst werden. Da muss ich mir halt, wenn ich das prinzipiell will, darüber Gedanken machen, wie ich das in Verhältnis setze zu den Gefahren, die dann auch von Überwachung ausgehen und so was. Und da kreisen dann so deren Gedanken um.
Also die wollen schon so ein bisschen Überwachung haben, aber in dem Fall wissen sie sozusagen auch darum, dass sie nicht so viele Überwachungsmöglichkeiten haben sollten? Oder ist es nur, dass sie Angst haben, von allen als Probener angesehen werden?
Es gibt solche und solche, es gibt natürlich einige, die hätten gerne alles, was geht, technisch. V.a. dann BKA und Verfassungsschutz und diese Leute, die keine Hemmung kennen. Das sieht man dann auch schön in diesem Bericht des Strafanwalts, was die dann wirklich auch schon alles machen. Das ist wirklich haarsträubend.
Kannst du da ruhig mal ein bisschen drauf eingehen? Also, jetzt mal ein paar Highlights. Mich interessiert jetzt vor allem wirklich diese Auseinandersetzung, was auch konkret an Studien und Erkenntnissen gewonnen wurde. Und auch, was jetzt hier aus der Praxis konkret berichtet wird. Ich erinnere mich hier noch sehr gut an den Vortrag von Udo Vetter auf dem letzten Kongress, wo er halt so, Sie haben das Recht zu schweigen. Hier ist der Vortrag fast legendär, wo es halt einfach nur um die Situation bei Hausdurchsuchungen geht. Also, wie muss man sich da verhalten, wo er dann eben auch so die Praxis der Polizisten immer wieder geschildert hat, die dann sich halt einfach über alle Regeln, vielleicht nicht über alle Regeln, aber doch zumindest über einige Regeln immer wieder hinweggesetzt haben und wo man dann schon sehr klar gesetzesbewusst sein muss und also wissen muss, wo die eigenen Rechte sind. Das wird halt auch dieser Titel, sie haben das Recht zu schweigen. Bei Überwachung ist es natürlich auch so eine ähnliche Geschichte. Was wird denn zum Beispiel in dem Beitrag dort auf den Tisch gelegt?
Na, da gibt es ein paar schöne Geschichten in dem Beitrag. Eine Sache, die ich ganz nett fand, war, nett in Anführungsstrichen, da ging es darum, wie schnell eigentlich diese, es gibt ja eine ganze Menge Reglementierung, ab wann man überwachen darf. Also grundrechtlich und gesetzlich ist es natürlich sehr formal, sehr schwierig, eine Überwachung überhaupt hinzubekommen. Also da muss schon sehr begründeter Verdacht und so weiter, dass man das überhaupt alles benutzen darf, diese ganzen Spielzeuge. Sodass man natürlich denken würde, okay, das ist jetzt nicht so leichtfertig, und da gibt es schon eine ganze Menge Vorschriften, die das, und ich muss mir da keine Sorgen machen. Da hat er aber dann einen Fall geschildert, zum Beispiel, den er hatte, also das sind viele schöne Sachen, da muss man einfach mal lesen, aber einen Fall, wo dann ein Informant, mit dem die Polizei öfters schon zusammengearbeitet hat, der hat dann der Polizei erzählt, der kennt da so einen Typen, der fährt öfters immer nach Holland. Ja, mehr nicht. Und daraufhin hat die Polizei gedacht, naja, könnte ja was sein, hat den dann drei Tage observiert, und dann stand irgendwie im Observationsbericht, ist nicht nach Holland gefahren, er hat sich nicht mit Drogenabhängigen getroffen, er hat keine großen Geldsummen, und er hat sich sogar beim Über-die-Straße-Gehen vorsichtig umgeguckt. Und dann ist dieser Bericht beim Kommissariate, ich weiß nicht, wo ist er, dann halt eben da gelandet, bei denen die dann entscheiden sollen, und dann wurde der Bericht interpretiert, und jetzt kommt, und zwar war dann die Quintessenz, dass dieser Herr sich ja sehr verdächtig verhalten würde, weil er ja nicht nach Holland gefahren wäre, also er hätte sozusagen gewusst, dass er überwacht wird, und würde sich jetzt extra nicht nach Holland fahren, er hätte sich extra nicht mit Drogensüchtigen getroffen, er hätte sich verdächtig umgesehen, ja, das war so dieses Überstraße-Gucken, also der war also sofort hochverdächtig, dann wurde eine Strafanzeige gestellt, aus einem Departement bei der Polizei, und dann wurde ein Tag später festgestellt, aha, hier gibt es ja auch noch eine Strafanzeige, ja, und dann war der sozusagen mit einem Schlag, obwohl er nichts gemacht hat, nie vorher irgendwie auffällig war, Ja, das ist ein ganz besonderes Thema. Mit einem Schlag war der hochverdächtig, einer der großen Drogenhändler zu sein. Und da wurde dann dieser gesamte Apparat angeschmissen. Er wurde lückenlos überwacht. Da gab es ein Kommando von zehn Personen, die sich da nur mit denen beschäftigt haben.
Das heißt, wenn man nichts zu verbergen hat, ist man eigentlich schon fast in der Top-Liste der Verdächtigen.
Ja, das ist total verdächtig.
Also Leute, die so unauffällig sind, die müssen ja was zu verbergen haben.
Ja, genau so wird es dann zum Teil gehandhabt.
Auweia.
Und so Storys sind da häufiger drin. Das sind nur irgendwelche Wagen, Hinweise und so weiter. Und dann rechtfertigt natürlich die Polizei damit auch die Existenz dieses Überwachungsapparates, dass der ja dauernd benutzt werden muss und so weiter.
Was ist so seine Quintessenz an der Stelle? Also so aus der Praxis heraus, des Juristischen?
Also die Quintessenz dieses von Herrn Lemke des Anwaltes ist dann eigentlich, dass man, dass die Polizei halt Grundrechte nur als Hindernisse ansieht und sich eigentlich drüber wegsetzt, sobald es irgendwie geht oder versucht, das irgendwie zu umgehen. Und dass sie überhaupt keine, die Polizei, die er kennengelernt hat in seiner Strafanwaltspraxis, überhaupt kein Verhältnis dazu hat, was da, was Grundrechte überhaupt bedeuten oder das auch nur einzuhalten, im Mindesten.
Weil das stört einfach?
Das stört bei der Ermittlungsarbeit und man könnte ja viel ungestörter arbeiten, wenn die Grundrechte nicht wären. Und besonders diese Freiheitsrechte.
Ja, wo kommen denn da auch hin? Das ist ja beunruhigend. Und die Datenschutzleute?
Die haben halt viel über ihren Umgang mit, also der Strafanwalt hat halt viel über seinen Umgang mit Polizisten geschrieben und auf der anderen Seite die Datenschutzleute haben natürlich mehr Umgang mit den Politikern. Besonders natürlich mit den Innenpolitikern, Innenministern und so weiter. Und die haben so ein bisschen geschrieben, was so ihr Eindruck ist, wie das Problembewusstsein der Politiker ist. Und da war so ein bisschen der Kanon, dass es eigentlich relativ frustrierend ist, weil die viele dafür, also gerade die Innenminister, überhaupt keine Relation dazu haben. Die wollen sich zwar geben Lippenbekenntnisse, aber intern gibt es dann so Sachen, dass man irgendwie berät, wie man Datenschutzabgeordnete zum Schweigen bringt oder wie man die irgendwie an die Seite drängt und versucht, die Mundtot zu machen oder sowas Geschichten. Also überhaupt kein Bewusstsein für diese Problematik da ist bei einigen Politikern. Es gibt natürlich jetzt auch andere, die sich unter dem jetzt stärker werdenden Druck der Öffentlichkeit schon auch ein bisschen kritischer damit beschäftigen. Aber es ist halt schwierig zu sagen, wo das jetzt hingeht. Also im Moment ist es natürlich auch ein bisschen Oppositionsrhetorik. Dass natürlich die Grünen und die FDP sich dann oppositionell gegen Schäuble wenden, weil den auch sowieso keiner mag.
Auf einmal finden die Grundrechte wieder ganz toll.
Vorher hätte es sie nicht interessiert, wenn sie...
Vorher haben die Grünen genauso Sicherheitsgesetze beschlossen und sich da dem Druck gebeugt. Also das ist ja... Keiner glaubt, glaube ich, der FDP, dass sie sich auch nur eine Sekunde dagegen gestemmt hat. Auch wenn es, muss man dazu sagen, nach wie vor unterdrückte Leute gibt, wie die Sabine Leuthäuser-Schnarrenberger, die sich da relativ explizit gegen den Trend stellt.
Es gibt ganz sicher ein paar Politiker, die auch ein Empfinden dafür haben, auch eine Relation. Aber es gibt halt auch viele, gerade die, mit denen sich die Datenschutzabgeordneten beschäftigen müssen, viele, die das mehr auch, genauso wie die Polizei, als Hindernis ansehen und irgendwie versuchen, darum zu schlawinern. Da ist auch in dem Text von dem Datenschutzabgeordneten auch sehr schöne Zitate, die er so erlebt hat mit Politikern.
Fällt dir was ein?
Nee, jetzt nicht. So gut kenne ich das Buch jetzt auch nicht, dass ich so auswendig Textpassagen zitieren kann.
Ja, aber du hast es bestimmt zweimal gelesen. Ein paar Mal. Bis man irgendwie nichts mehr sieht. Ein anderer Teil hier in diesem Praxisteil beschäftigt sich mit Kosten und Nutzen technisierter Überwachung. Ein Kriminologe ist hier zu Wort gekommen. Hans-Jörg Albrecht.
Hans-Jörg Albrecht ist der Leiter des Deutschen Max Planck-Institutes für Kriminologie. Er ist auch ein recht renommierter Kriminalwissenschaftler.
Der müsste es wissen.
Ja, er weiß es. Sein Beitrag strotzt gerade von Studien. Er hat die Vorgabe gehabt, mal zu illustrieren, wie man überhaupt Kosten- und Nutzenerwägungen von Überwachungen in der Kriminalistik erstellt. Das ist natürlich auch jenseits aller Fragen, was für Gefahren dahinterstecken. Es ist natürlich auch immer noch mal interessant, überhaupt mal diese Cost-Benefit-Ratios zu sehen von Überwachungsmaßnahmen. Dass man einfach sieht, was für ein Output erhält man im Verhältnis zu den Kosten, die das Ganze verursacht. Und das ist auch ein sehr interessanter Artikel von ihm. Zum einen, weil er halt sagt, man kann die Kosten nicht nur rein monetär berechnen, sondern man muss wirklich in die Kostenpunkte auch den Verlust der Grundrechte einrechnen. Das ist sozusagen keine reinen Geldrechnungen, die man da aufmacht. Das ist schon mal interessant. Und was dann aber noch viel interessanter ist, ist, dass er so einen Überblick gibt über die ganzen Studien, die es gibt, zur Effektivität von Überwachungsmaßnahmen. Und da ist eigentlich das Interessante, dass es extrem wenig Studien gibt zur Effektivität von Überwachungsmaßnahmen. Zum Teil natürlich auch, weil die sehr jung sind, zum Teil aber auch, weil die einfach kein Geld dafür ausgeben. Und das ist bei einigen Maßnahmen ganz erstaunlich, wie zum Beispiel der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die jetzt europaweit durchgesetzt wurde. Und normalerweise als Normalbürger würde man ja denken, da gibt es jetzt profunde wissenschaftliche Kenntnisse, die belegen, dass das irgendwie total effektiv ist, total effizient. Und zum Beispiel bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist es halt eben so, dass die auf Basis einer einzigen Studie eingeführt wurde als EU-Richtlinie. Und diese eine einzige Studie kam von einem Institut in Holland, das sich 30 Fälle oder so, also eine richtig niedrige Zahl, 30 Fälle ausgesucht hat, vorher ausgesucht hat, explizit bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gemacht wurde, Verkehrsdatenanalyse und wo dann halt die zu einem Verhandlungserfolg geführt haben. Also so eine richtig, grob gesagt, getürkte Geschichte. Und da gibt es noch eine ganze Menge anderer Beispiele, wo dann halt auch kritischere Kriminologen untersuchen, wie effizient das denn überhaupt ist alles. Und da eröffnet sich, also in diesem Artikel eröffnet sich einem nochmal so ein ganz anderer Abgrund, dass man nämlich bei diesen ganzen Maßnahmen, technischen Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die da so durchgepaukt werden, überhaupt gar nicht weiß, ob die überhaupt was bringen. Also man weiß um die ganzen Gefahren, Abbau der Grundrechte, aber ob die auch wirklich Terroristen fangen oder Kinder pornographen oder sowas, ist überhaupt nicht erwiesen.
Bei gar keiner technischen Maßnahme?
Bei vielen, es gibt natürlich Untersuchungen, aber es sind halt viele jetzt noch nicht so sehr viele Untersuchungen, um wirklich solide, objektive Erkenntnisse zu geben in vielen Bereichen. Telekommunikationsüberwachung ist relativ gut erforscht. Da ist es dann aber zum Beispiel so, dass die Hälfte aller Fälle, die über Telekommunikationsüberwachung vors Gericht kommen, nicht mal, also oder die ermittelt werden, nicht mal vor Gericht kommen von Telekommunikationsüberwachung, weil sich einfach dann doch keine ausreichende Beweislage ergibt. Und bei vielen anderen Fällen ist es dann einfach so, dass die auch mit klassischer Ermittlungsarbeit hätten rausgefunden werden können. Also zum Beispiel auch bei dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherung gab es danach noch mal eine Untersuchung und da kam dann raus, dass von diesen 30 sowieso schon getürkten Ergebnissen auch noch die Hälfte sowieso auf klassischen Wege hätte erledigt werden können, genauso schnell. Und das ist dann natürlich noch mal eine ganz andere Dimension, wenn man so diese ganzen empirischen Untersuchungen dazu sich mal ansieht, wie auf was für dünnen Beinen auch diese ganzen Maßnahmen stehen.
Das heißt, es gibt eigentlich kaum Studien, die in irgendeiner Form belegen, dass Kosten und Nutzen in einem sinnvollen Verhältnis stehen? Also es gibt schon welche, aber gibt es welche, die wissenschaftlich anerkannt sind?
Es gibt schon welche, aber nicht in dem Verhältnis, die sind auch wissenschaftlich anerkannt, aber nicht in einem Verhältnis, das den gegenwärtigen Abbau von Grundrechten damit rechtfertigen würde.
Das heißt, sie haben einen Nutzen, aber sie sind extrem invasiv, was die Grundrechte betrifft.
Na ja, sie schaffen faktisch eine ganze Menge Grundrechte ab. Diese Überwachungsprobleme, die wir kurz angesprochen hatten, kommen dann zum Tragen. Die Misstrauensatmosphäre, die Missbrauchsgefahr, diese psychologischen Beobachtereffekte, dass man kein Privatgefühl mehr hat, die kommen alle zum Tragen, also alles Serialegefahren. Die Ausbeute, die man dafür hat für diese ganzen Opfer, die man bringt, ist dann auch noch total gering und unbewiesen, dass es überhaupt so was bringt. Das ist dann auch nochmal eine interessante Überlegung, finde ich, jenseits aller Gefahrenmomente, dass man sozusagen diese ganzen Gefahren auch noch eingeht für relativ wenig Gewinn.
Ich habe so den Eindruck, der dritte Teil beschäftigt sich dann im Prinzip aus den Fragen, die daraus, sozusagen aus dieser Praxis-Schilderung auch entstehen. So ist das überhaupt sinnvoll und so. Keine Freiheit ohne Privatsphäre heißt hier ein Abschnitt. Da wird kulturphilosophisch herangegangen, ist das richtig? Jessica Hesen, wer ist das?
Das ist eine Kulturphilosophin in Stuttgart, eine Kollegin von mir da, eine zukünftige. Die hat auch ihre Doktorarbeit geschrieben zur Freiheit, Privatsphäre, Überwachung. Kennt sich da sehr gut aus. Und der Artikel ist halt auch sehr schön. Und das ist eigentlich ein schöner Follow-up-Artikel, sozusagen. Weil sie da sehr genau versucht und diesen Bekannten in der Begriff Freiheit überhaupt mal materialfest zu machen. Man sagt immer Freiheit. Was bedeutet eigentlich Freiheit? Was meint man eigentlich? Wo ist man eigentlich frei? Was muss man haben, um frei zu sein? Das ist natürlich einmal dieser psychologische Aspekt. Der ist jetzt in dem Buchlein nicht drin, weil da der zuständige Psychologe ausgefallen ist mit seinem Beitrag. Aber aus der kulturphilosophischen Perspektive kann man das halt auch aufrollen. Und da hat sie halt sehr schön und sehr präzise und klar demonstriert, dass Freiheit eigentlich nur mit einer gewissen Privatsphäre existiert. Das sagt ja auch dieser Titel aus, keine Freiheit ohne Privatsphäre. Das beweist es wirklich sehr deutlich, dass alles, was wir unter Freiheit verstehen, also macht da zum Beispiel, sich frei zu entscheiden, so eine dezisionale Freiheit heißt das. Oder sein eigenes Leben zu leben, so wie man will. Auch mal in der Unterhose rumrennen, in Anführungsstrichen. Dass das eigentlich alles private Räume erfordert. Dass diese ganzen Sachen, die man unter frei versteht, nur unter Privathit stattfinden können. Dass man einen privaten Ort hat, dass man in seinen Gedanken privat ist und so was. Und das ist dann so eine sehr schöne kulturphilosophische Argumentation, wie Freiheit eigentlich runtergebrochen werden muss auf diesen Begriff der Privathit, ohne den sich der Begriff der Freiheit nicht mehr sinnvoll formulieren lässt. Und wenn man dann das natürlich hat, und man weiß, es gibt keine Freiheit ohne Privatsphäre und Überwachung schafft Privatsphäre auf technische Weise ab, dann hat man natürlich dieses Politiker-Rhetorik-Argument, die Freiheit verteidigen mit Überwachungstechnik.
Weißt sich selbst in den Schwanz sozusagen.
Also das ist auch so ein Beispiel, was ich sehr schön finde, für viele Argumentationen in dem Band, die halt gerade diese verquere politische Rhetorik dann mal auf die reale Basis runterbrechen. Die dann halt sagen, okay, die Politiker schwafeln hier, Demokratie, Rechtsstaat verteidigen, bla bla bla. Aber was bedeutet Demokratie? Was bedeutet Rechtsstaat? Was produziert Überwachung? Wie funktionieren diese Argumente miteinander, die Werte, die damit zusammenhängen? Und da ist es dann in allen Beiträgen, die sich mit dieser Fragestellung beschäftigen, wirklich so, dass sich das Verhältnis eben gerade genau umkehrt. Dass genau diese rhetorischen Argumente der Politiker, die uns immer so eingebläut werden, sich als total absurd und genau andersrum vorausstellen. Nur halt eben auf eine sehr solide, informierte Art und Weise.
Dieser dritte Abschnitt heißt ja Phänomen der Überwachung. Wie seid ihr auf den Titel gekommen?
Was ist das?
Klingt so, als wäre das so was Neues, so was weiß ich, das Phänomen der Internetsucht oder...
Nee, das Phänomen hat einfach in der Philosophie einen anderen Kontext. Die Gestalt, also einfach die Erscheinung der Überwachung. Was bedeutet das jetzt, dieses neue Phänomen der Überwachung? Also neu jetzt aber.
Das heißt, da passt dann auch rein, dieser Geschichtsüberblick, die Überwachung.
Da haben wir einen Techniksoziologe, der führt da den Abschnitt an. Werner Rammann, der bekannte Techniksoziologe in Deutschland. Der schreibt zum Beispiel, es gibt ja diese Diskussion über Wissenschaft, kennst du die? Das Upgrade von der Update zur Informationsgesellschaft. Dass die Wissensgesellschaft sozusagen auf Wissen basiert und auf Expertenwissen und da analysiert er jetzt diese ganze Beschaffung von Daten durch Überwachung oder durch Datamining mal unter diesem Aspekt einer Gesellschaft, die auf der Basis von Wissen entscheidet und macht dann diese ganzen Daten, die gesammelt werden, fest als Machtmittel. Also die Leute, die Daten sammeln, die besorgen sich damit Macht über die Leute, über die sie etwas wissen. Weil halt diese Daten es ihnen ermöglichen, gezielter Einfluss zu nehmen, die Leute zu manipulieren, zu dirigieren, zu regieren. Und gezielter manipulativer oder auch regierter kontrolliert.
Weil man ihr Verhalten kennt, ihre Vorlieben kennt.
Genau, und da kann man dann mit den ganzen Instrumenten, Psychologie, PR, drauf Einfluss nehmen und so weiter.
Das spielt dann auch in Sachen rein wie Payback-Karten, wo man sein ganzes Einkaufsverhalten offenlegt, etc. Oder den von Politikern gewünschten Zugriff auf Datenbanken von Einzelhandelsystemen, oben was weiß ich, zu verhindern.
Da geht es ganz allgemein um Daten, was Daten sind und was die Macht der Leute ausmacht, die Daten besitzen, die Daten produzieren in einer Gesellschaft, die ihre Entscheidungen zunehmend stärker von Wissen abhängig macht. Also ein sehr interessanter Beitrag auch in dem Kontext. Und das ist halt auch so ein bisschen illustrativ für das, was so Phänomen der Überwachung bedeuten soll, dass man halt mal sieht, wie Überwachung überhaupt in welchen Formen, die überhaupt so wahrnehmbar ist in ihren gesellschaftlichen Einbettungen und sowas.
Ja, also es sind ja hier so viele, also jetzt habe ich gesagt, wir wollen ja nicht so viel über das Buch reden. Jetzt fangen wir uns hier doch so ein bisschen durch das Inhaltsverzeichnis, weil ich finde einfach die Aspekte sehr interessant, die hier beleuchtet werden. Also euch ist es ja da offensichtlich gelungen, da sehr einen breiten Ansatz zu wählen, sowohl jetzt von den Leuten, die dort beigetragen haben, als eben auch jetzt von diesen Hauptpositionen. Habt ihr schon erwähnt hier, Technik, Praxis, Phänomen. Und das mündet dann in die Werte. Was ist das für ein Ansatz, die Werte der Überwachung? Wessen Werte sind denn hier gemeint?
Das ist jetzt sozusagen mein aktivistischer Impuls, der dann die ganzen praktischen und theoretischen Bewertungen und Erkenntnisgewinnen in der Frage münden lässt, wie sollen wir uns denn jetzt eigentlich damit verhalten. Das ist natürlich dann auch nach wie vor eine wichtige Frage, wenn man sich jetzt diese ganzen Erkenntnisse angeeignet hat und man weiß, was für Gefahren es gibt, wie das real praktiziert wird und was das für eine Ausdehnung in der Gesellschaft hat. Und so weiter, dass man dann aber auch eben vor der Frage steht, was kann ich denn jetzt machen, wie soll ich denn damit umgehen, was soll ich jetzt, wie kann ich mich da abstimmen oder politisch verhalten und so was. Und das sind halt Fragen, die dann in diesem Kapitel Werte der Überwachung aufgegriffen werden sollen. Also geht es halt ganz klar um juristische Fragestellungen, wird ja auch angeführt von einem Rechtswissenschaftler, von Gerrit Hornung, der ist da bei dem Rossnagel im Team, ein sehr bekannter Jurist in der ganzen Überwachungsgeschichte.
Datenschutz im Gefüge der Grundrechte.
Und da wird so ein bisschen diese Basis, wie das überhaupt vom Gesetz gehandhabt wird, evaluiert. Und da geht es halt schon um die Werte auch, die dahinterstehen. Also da wird dann der Wert der Freiheit, der Schutz des Lebens und der Information, was das überhaupt bedeutet, rechtlich wird dann alles evaluiert und illustriert und an Entscheidungen des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, auch jüngeren Entscheidungen, mal ein bisschen klargemacht, wie sich das alles so verändert. Das ist auch eine sehr interessante Situation, weil natürlich die ganzen Gesetze, die dafür existieren, für Freiheit und die Freiheit definieren und Selbstbestimmung definieren, die kommen natürlich alle aus einer Zeit, in der es diese ganzen technischen Möglichkeiten noch nicht gab. Es gibt ja diese Parallele auch in der Copyright-Diskussion, dass halt eben diese ganzen Copyright-Gesetze alle aus einer Zeit kommen, wo es diese Möglichkeit nicht gab, digital einfach zu kopieren. Wo einfach sozusagen ein Copyright durch die Macht des Fabrikbesitzers, der Bestand, die Sachen einfach einzig und allein weiter produzieren zu können. Die Macht hat sich jetzt technisch verändert, also neue Situationen muss man diese Gesetze neu überdenken. Und das ist im Grunde genommen das Gleiche mit Überwachung. Weil sich halt mit den neuen technischen Möglichkeiten und auch dadurch, dass wir so viel unseres Lebens jetzt mit digitalen Technologien vermitteln und leben und so viel unser Leben damit auch teilen, ganz neue Möglichkeiten des Eingriffs ergeben haben, ganz neue Möglichkeiten, Freiheit zu definieren, Informationen zu definieren. Und von daher ist das ein ganz interessanter Artikel, weil er diese ganzen Entscheidungen mal so ein bisschen nachskizziert, die das Bundesverfassungsgericht dazu betroffen hat, um mal so ein bisschen die Position des Gesetzgebers zu diesen Werten und zu der Veränderung in der neuen technischen Situation zu illustrieren.
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht ist ja eigentlich noch ein großer Fan von diesen Grundrechten.
Ah ja, dafür sind sie ja da.
Ja, das finde ich auch schon mal ganz gut. Ich meine, nicht jedes Verfassungsgericht in allen Ländern verhält sich unbedingt jetzt so, dass man das Gefühl hat, dass sie auch wirklich diese Verfassung achten und ehren. Allerdings habe ich den Glauben, dass es sich bei den Politikern ähnlich verhält, eigentlich schon weitgehend eingewüst. Das ist nicht so. Jetzt gibt es hier eine weitere Betrachtung unter dem Thema der heimliche Terror der Profilaxe. Ich habe jetzt so eine Vermutung, was hier für ein Kapitel aufgeschlagen wird, aber das ist sozusagen die Argumentation, dass die Überfachung selber ein Terror ist.
Das ist der Beitrag von Günter Ropow, ein sehr schöner, sehr klarer, philosophischer Beitrag. Günter Ropow ist ein ganz berühmter Technikphilosoph in Deutschland, einer der großen Technikphilosophen. Er hat jetzt einen sehr schönen technikethischen Artikel geschrieben. Den wollte ich auch gerne drin haben, weil er sich sehr viele Gedanken gemacht hat um Technikethik und wie man mit Technik verantwortlich umgehen kann. Er erklärt erst mal sehr allgemeinverständlich, was Technikethik überhaupt ist, was man sich darunter vorstellen kann, wie man sich das denken kann. Man beschreibt dann Tabellen von moralischen Werten, die aufeinander abgestimmt sind, also auch Schutz des Lebens und Schutz der Freiheit und solche Geschichten. Und zieht dann daraus Rückschlüsse letzten Endes, wie diese ganze Einführung von Überwachungstechnik unter dieser Terrorrhetorik zu bewerten, ist ethisch. Und kommt dann eben zu dem Schluss, dass seine Quintessenz ist, die Gefahr des Terrors ist eine abstrakte, hypothetische Gefahr. Es könnte was passieren. Während die Gefahr der Überwachungstechnik, dadurch, dass sie ja schon real umgesetzt ist, eine ganz reale, praktische Gefahr ist. Dieses Missbrauchspotenzial, diese psychologischen Geschichten und so was. Und da ist so ein bisschen dann, also sein Argument ist ein bisschen, das beinhaltet natürlich mehr, ein bisschen die Quintessenz ist halt, dass hier eine reale Gefahr eingeführt wird, um eine hypothetische Gefahr abzuwehren. Und das ist halt eben ethisch nicht vertretbar. Und auf die Art pervertiert halt diese Terrorprophylaxe zum Terror selber.
Die Sachen mit dem Missbrauch hatten wir ja auch schon am Anfang. Und ich halte das auch ehrlich gesagt für eines der wichtigsten Argumente in dieser ganzen Diskussion. Gibt es denn dazu auch Studien, die dieses Missbrauchs, also sagen wir mal den Hang, der Leute, die Zugriff haben auf Überwachungstechnik, zu einem Missbrauch irgendwie untersucht?
Na, da gibt es eine große Studie, die heißt Geschichte. Da ist jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen...
Die heißt Geschichte?
Na ja, da guck doch mal in die Geschichte der Menschheit. Da ist immer so ein bisschen... Ich hab jetzt ein schönes Zitat von einem Kollegen von mir. Das Einzige, was man aus der Geschichte lernen kann, ist, dass man nichts aus der Geschichte gelernt hat. Aber wenn du irgendwie eine Studie suchst, was Überwachungsmöglichkeiten so alles ergeben, dann musst du jetzt noch mal in die DDR gucken. Kannst du dir die Nazis angucken. Kannst du dir auch jetzt gerade China angucken oder die USA. Kannst du gucken, wer da in Guantanamo sitzt und auf Basis welcher technischer Prozesse die Ermittlungsverfahren stattgefunden haben.
Ja gut, aber das ist nicht genau das, was ich meine. Was ich meine, ist ja, also bei der DDR, bei den Nazis könnte man ja auch noch argumentieren, da ist ja die Technik eigentlich auch schon gleich mit einem Missbrauchsansatz implementiert worden. Das ist jetzt sicherlich noch meine eigene philosophische Diskussion. Die will ich jetzt auch gar nicht führen. Aber so gerade unter diesem, naja, es ist ja nur für unsere aller Sicherheit. Und das Ding ist, ich glaube sogar, diesen meisten Politikern, die sich überhaupt trauen, ihre Stimme zu erheben, aber die dann später auch vielleicht für sowas stimmen, dass sie ein Stück weit das auch tatsächlich glauben. Also sie glauben tatsächlich, dass sie irgendwas tun, was hilft. Weil sie einfach diese Sache schon gar nicht so wissenschaftlich, aber auch sonst wahrscheinlich nicht ausreichend durchdacht haben. Und da einfach besten Mutes sind. Und wenn man auch so den Einzelnen auf der Straße fragt, naja, sie werden ja jetzt überwacht und so weiter. Wie sehen sie denn das Misstrauenspotenzial? Dann hört man ja häufig so dieses, ich hab da das Vertrauen, dass das nicht passiert. Deswegen meine Frage, gibt es denn Untersuchungen, wo solche Systeme, die jetzt wirklich da sind, die etabliert wurden und die, sagen wir mal, in so einem Gesamtgesellschaften oder welchen Konsens auch immer geschaffen wurden, naja, das soll uns jetzt helfen, dieses Problem zu beheben. Gibt es da irgendwie Erkenntnisse, dass dann eben es doch im Wesentlichen oder zumindest so einen bestimmten Prozentsatz in Missbrauch mündete?
Ne, das kann man natürlich auch nicht untersuchen.
Echt nicht? Ich dachte, Wissenschaftler können alles.
Fast alles. Nein, das ist natürlich was, was man nicht untersuchen kann. Das sind natürlich dann große historische Prozesse. Es gibt natürlich diese These von der Neutralität der Technik, die in der Technikphilosophie viel diskutiert wurde, am eloquentesten, wie ich finde, übrigens von Stanislav Lem in seiner Summa Technologia. Wo es dann darum geht, jetzt habe ich den verantworten, was habe ich gesagt?
Die Missbrauchsgeschichte.
Dass jede Technik, die prinzipiell für irgendwas Schlechtes benutzt werden kann, dann auch für was Ruhl, für was Gutes, als auch für was Schlechtes benutzt werden kann. Ein Beispiel ist dann irgendwie Technologien, die beim Holocaust benutzt wurden. War jetzt die Technik an sich schlecht oder gut oder sowas, kann man irgendwie schlecht sagen. Ob die Technik an sich auch zum Missbrauch eingeladen hat oder nicht, kann man auch schwer sagen.
Aber man muss immer davon ausgehen.
Man muss davon ausgehen. Ich habe eigentlich in meinem Beitrag, das kann ich mal was zum einen Beitrag sagen, die Vergeistigung des Technotops, ein bisschen philosophischerer Titel. Das Technotops, da kann ich gleich noch was zu sagen. Erstmal zum Missbrauchsding. Es gibt natürlich keine Untersuchungen, die jetzt sagen, das ist eine Technik, die mündet definitiv in Missbrauch. Jede Technik kann, wenn sie gut kontrolliert wird, kann das auch, und im Moment ist es ja auch so, dass es keine faktische Missbrauchslage gibt, in Deutschland zumindest nicht. Das ist ja auch eben das Problem, diese Missbrauchsgefahr als aktuelle Gefahr zu erkennen, weil es im Moment nicht stattfindet. Das heißt ja nicht, dass es morgen nicht stattfindet. Aber man kann halt an Technologien, das ist eine von meinen Thesen gewesen, dass man Technologien festmachen kann, die sich schon sehr deutlich dem Missbrauch anbieten. Es gab damals mal im Zuge der Industrialisierung das sogenannte Versprechen der Technik. Daran habe ich das festgemacht. Das ist, glaube ich, auch eine ganz gute Art und Weise, das zu betrachten. Das Versprechen der Technik war damals, die Menschheit von Not und Übel zu erlösen. Damit wurde halt Industrialisierung betrieben. Man hat gesagt, man muss jetzt mal ein paar Opfer bringen. Dafür wird uns die Technik und sichere Nahrungsmittel und Housing und alles Mögliche produzieren. Die Technik wird uns für immer von Not und Übel befreien. Es waren ja auch diese Uhrzeiten der alten technischen Utopien, die es dann gab, wo dann alle nur noch den ganzen Tag im Bett liegen und sich sparen.
Fliegende Autos.
Und ja, keiner muss mehr was tun. Weiß man inzwischen, wäre technisch möglich gewesen, ist nicht passiert. Versprechende Technik. Deswegen ist es auch so ein bisschen in Vergessenheit geraten. Aber was man, finde ich, noch ganz gut an dem Versprechen festmachen kann, ist so, was eine missbrauchstendenziöse Technologie ist. Und zwar, wenn man das Versprechen mal so variiert, diese Befreiung der Menschheit oder des Menschen von Not und Übel in so eine bisschen konkrete Formel, die Befreiung aller Menschen von Not und Übel. Das ist ja so ein bisschen konkreter als dieses abstrakte Befreiung der Menschheit, sondern die Befreiung aller Menschen von Not und Übel. Und dann kann man sagen, dass eine Technologie, die in der Art und Weise, wie sie benutzt werden kann, die Befreiung einiger Menschen auf Kosten anderer Menschen favorisiert, tendenziell Missbrauch bevorzugt oder missbräuchliche Arten und Weise. Da würde ich sozusagen den Missbrauch von Technik sehen, wenn man Technik benutzt, um sich selbst zu bereichern an anderen.
Also Technik, die jetzt potenziell repressive Nutzen aufmöglichkeit hat.
Repressiv oder man kann also auch ganz viel industrielle Technik, ist halt so ausgelegt, dass die halt bestimmte gesellschaftliche Systeme asymmetrisch präferiert und so.
Kannst du mal ein Beispiel nennen?
Ein Beispiel, zum Beispiel halt die stalinischen Großindustrieen und so was, die halt eben nur mit zentralisierter Kontrolle betrieben werden konnten. Diese riesigen Stahlschminen, riesigen Kohleschminen, die waren so ausgelegt, dass die nur auf zentralisierter, stark zentralisierter Kontrolle basiert haben. Und das hat halt eben diese stark zentralisierte Kontrolle, also diese stark asymmetrische Kontrolle auch mit am Leben gehalten, mit produziert, mit am Leben gehalten. Und das ist halt so eine Asymmetrie, die ist eine gesellschaftliche Asymmetrie, die sozusagen auch technisch gestützt wurde durch diese Anlage.
Also die Asymmetrie ist, dass sozusagen der Nutzen nur für wenige ist?
Ja, der Nutzen ist für wenige, auf Kosten vieler.
Und die dann dort unter schlechten Bedingungen gearbeitet haben oder ihr Leben verloren haben?
Naja, oder halt eben dadurch, dass einfach diese zentralen Kräfte dann halt eben auch zentral darüber verfügt haben, wer was bekommt, wo das benutzt wird und so weiter. Und Überwachungstechnik ist halt asymmetrisch angelegt. Also Überwachungstechnik hat den Sinn sozusagen, dass jetzt ganz viele mit ganz geringem Aufwand überwacht werden können. Das ist ja ganz geringer Aufwand, also McStreet ist halt so ein Pyramidales Modell, dass sozusagen dann ein Überwacher da oben sitzt und der überwacht dann alles, was der Durchschnittsbürger so elektronisch kommuniziert. Inzwischen ist es ja tatsächlich technisch so realisiert mit diesen ganzen Profiling-Programmen und so, die dann halt deine Kommunikation automatisch durchwursteln und Profile erstellen und so weiter. Und das ist ja alles schon so schön vorbereitet, dass man wirklich nur noch mit einem Team von 5, 6 Leuten im Grunde da alles auswerten kann.
Das heißt, es fehlt auch so ein bisschen die inherente Kontrolle des Apparats selber, weil er viel zu klein ist. Also ist ja immer so die Frage, in dem Moment, wo jemand ein Kontrollinstrument hat, so, dann steht es ja einer Gesellschaft gut zu Gesicht, für dieses kontrollierende Element auch ein Kontrollgremium zu haben, was sozusagen diese Ausführung kontrolliert. Die Gremien, die wir jetzt so derzeit haben, so wie PKG da wirklich greifen, da habe ich schweren Bedenken. Allerdings ist es natürlich gerade so bei digitaler Technik, umso mehr Software da irgendwie arbeitet, umso komplexer die Modelle sind. Gerade wenn du sagst Profiling und so, wer soll denn das bitte noch überblicken? Also ist ja auch die Komplexität der Technologie nochmal ein eigenes Problem in sich.
Ja, na das ist vielleicht nochmal eine andere Sache, aber auf jeden Fall ist es eine Technologie, die durch diese Asymetrie der Nutzung auch stark zu Missbrauch einlädt. Also da kann man einfach viele Menschen kontrollieren mit sehr wenig Mitteln und sehr wenig Aufwand. Und das bietet sich einfach den Missbrauch sehr an. Also das ist so das, was ich vielleicht dazu sagen würde. Man kann jetzt nicht so direkt sagen, okay, das ist so eine Art technologieproduziert Missbrauch, aber man kann sagen, dass sich bestimmte Technologien missbräuchlichen Verwendungen doch sehr zuneigen.
Jetzt würde ich ganz gerne noch mal zum Abschluss noch mal so kurz hier auf den technischen Teil gehen, der so eingangs stattfindet. Wir hatten ja schon erwähnt, einige Leute, die auch so aus ihren Aktivitäten im Club bekannt sind, sind hier mit vertreten in diesem Buch. Allen voran natürlich Constanze, die jetzt Mit-Herausgeberin ist, die sich zur Biometrie äußert. Aber noch hier den Frank Grieger, auch schon einige Male zu Gast gewesen bei Chaosradio Express. Natürlich auch bei Chaosradio, seit Ewigkeiten war früher Sprecher auch im Club, der sich über Telefonüberwachung, wie sich das richtig, veräußert hat. Also eine technische Ausführung über den Stand der Dinge bei Telefonüberwachung. Dirk Engeling macht dasselbe dann mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Also das heißt, das ist so eine technische Beschreibung, was bekannt ist.
Ein bisschen eine technische Beschreibung, aber dann auch eher, wie es verwendet wird, wie das so die aktuelle Lage ist, wohin sich es entwickeln wird.
Und dann haben wir hier auch noch andere Leute. Wolfgang Coy ist ja hier auch von der Humboldt-Universität in Berlin.
Ein damals bekannter Technikforscher.
Ja, technische Überwachung und Seiten des Internets. Das ist eher so eine generelle Einführung in das Thema. Und das klingt doch alles sehr interessant. Das heißt, dieses Buch ist so eine Art Kompendium zum Thema Überwachung. Was ist so deine persönliche Essenz, die du jetzt so ziehst aus der Arbeit an diesem Buch? Das war ja bestimmt ein ziemlich langer Ritt.
Ja, hat es jetzt gedauert ungefähr.
Was für eine Erkenntnis hat das Werk in seiner Summe auch für dich gebracht?
Mir hat es sehr viele verschiedene Einsichten tatsächlich auch noch mal gebracht, gerade diese Perspektiven, von denen ich ja einige jetzt auch nicht so fundiert gehört habe, wie sie in dem Band jetzt vertreten sind. Bei mir haben sich eigentlich die Argumente mehr so vervielfacht, wie man Überwachungen sehen kann, was man dagegen tun sollte, oder wie man das überhaupt politisiert und dass man sich darum kümmern muss und weiter aufklären muss, dass diese Argumente auch ein bisschen in die Öffentlichkeit kommen. Ich finde, da leistet der Band jetzt wirklich, ich will jetzt keine Werbung machen, aber ich bin jetzt auch wirklich mit dem Constanze auf, wir sind beide mit dem Endresultat, der Verlag auch, da sind wir alle sehr zufrieden, das, was wir jetzt haben. Weil die Aufgabenstellung war natürlich relativ schwierig, dieses komplexe Phänomen wirklich mit diesen ganzen verschiedenen Perspektiven mal in einem Band zusammenzubringen. Und dann nicht nur, dass man so lauter getrennte Perspektiven hat, sondern dass man die auch miteinander verbinden kann und so einen soliden, fundamentierten, fundierten Gesamteindruck bekommt. Und das ist uns dann tatsächlich gelungen, auf eine sehr verständliche Art und Weise, in eine sehr informative Weise. Und ich glaube, jeder, der sich für das Thema Überwachung interessiert, wird in diesem Buch wirklich ein sehr gutes Handbuch finden, um sich darüber zu informieren, um auch ganz verschiedene Sachen, Aspekte daran kennenzulernen und dann eben auch sehr gut und informiert an dem entsprechenden politischen Prozess teilzunehmen.
Die Liste der Autoren ist ja relativ lang, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass ihr nicht nur Zusagen erhalten habt, sondern dass es irgendwie fehlt noch was. Geht das weiter mit dem Projekt? Ist das jetzt so eine einmalige Geschichte oder gibt es jetzt irgendwie da noch ein Follow-up zu dem?
Wir müssen jetzt mal gucken, wir werden bestimmt nochmal in eine zweite Auflage gehen, vielleicht auch nochmal in eine dritte. Ich hatte eigentlich noch mehr Sachen konzipiert, noch mehr Beiträge auch geplant und angeschrieben, sind da wieder ausgefallen leider. Ich hatte zum Beispiel, also natürlich waren eigentlich zwei Beiträge noch geplant für die Befürworter, einmal für die BKA-Verfassungsschutzleute und dann halt aber auch für die Innenminister, dass die mal so ihre politische Position äußern, gehört ja eigentlich auch in so einen Band rein. Das waren auch den Politikern und auch den Entscheidungsträgern, die Überwachung einführen. Dass man die auch mal befragt, was dann eigentlich ihre Argumente dazu sind und wie sie dazu stehen. Aber es hat sich ja schon erwähnt, dass sie einfach nicht wollten. Absagen, die wollten nicht und waren komisch. Und das war jetzt ein bisschen anstrengend. Ja, ist natürlich jetzt ein Phänomen für sich, vor allen Dingen auch in der Masse, in der wir wirklich sehr viele kontaktiert haben. Wir haben wirklich eine große, obwohl wir bei allen anderen sofort Zusagen bekommen haben und sofort für das gute Projekt und die gute Idee auch gleich Zustimmung gefunden haben, war da halt wirklich durch die Bank massenweise Absagen. Also so ein richtiges Begleitphänomen, sozusagen, dass sich die Befürworter lieber nicht äußern wollen.
Weil sie sich ihrer Sachen nicht sicher sind?
Ich keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich wollen die einfach nicht in die Diskussion kommen. Da wird glaube ich keiner mit seinem Namen irgendwie in diesem Ding stehen und dann sagen, ich will Überwachung. Das ist ein bisschen, glaube ich, dahinter.
Mit der einzigen Ausnahme.
Mit der lotenswerten Ausnahme von Rainer Wendt auf jeden Fall. Aber ich finde halt eben, man müsste Kritik jetzt weniger an solchen Personen wie Rainer Wendt üben, die sich dann wenigstens noch dem Diskurs stellen und versuchen, sondern wirklich mehr mal die Leute, die dann auch schon so gar keine Bereitschaft mehr dazu haben, sich überhaupt noch dazu zu äußern, was sie da machen. Das ist viel schlimmer. Ein richtig undemokratisches Grundverhältnis auch dazu. Also die hätte ich auf jeden Fall natürlich gerne drin, wenn es noch mal eine Ausgabe gibt. Vielleicht kann ich dir noch so ein bisschen drangsalieren. Dann andere Beiträge, die gefehlt haben. Ich hatte noch einen von einem bekannten Science-Fiction-Forscher drin gehabt, der so ein bisschen was über Überwachungsdystopien geschrieben hätte. Also wie Überwachung, was für eine Rolle Überwachungstechnologien in der Science-Fiction spielt. Gibt es ja in vielen Dystopien spielt ja Überwachung eine Schlüsselrolle. 1984 natürlich. Und dann aber halt auch Minority Report oder Matrix.
Das war auch ein Titel geholt sozusagen.
Das wäre noch schön gewesen. Da gab es leider ein Missverständnis, weil der noch an einem anderen Band zusammen mit mir arbeitet. Und da dachte dann der andere hebt diesen auf oder irgendwas. Dann Technikpsychologe hatte ich eigentlich noch geplant gehabt. Das wäre natürlich auch sehr schön gewesen, den drin zu haben. Aber der ist das, was jemand krank geworden. Der konnte dann leider nicht. Vielleicht kommt der noch mit in die zweite Auflage. Und dann hätte ich natürlich auch gerne den Club als politischen Akteur drin gehabt. Das ist dann leider an Andi Müller-Marc Unge-Scheiter. Der hat sein Bier komplett versemmelt. Na ja, vielleicht hätte ich mich nicht lange so ausdehnen. Das finde ich aber auch sehr schade, weil mir persönlich das natürlich auch sehr wichtig gewesen wäre, den Club, also den Datenschutzaktivisten, der sicherlich auch eine ganze Menge eigene Erfahrungen hat mit dem Thema und auch eine ganz eigene Perspektive zu dem Thema mit hätte reinbringen können und eigene Erfahrungen. Dass der jetzt so gar nicht vertreten ist. Also natürlich in den Technikabschnitten so. Da natürlich auch fundiert und berechtigt, aber leider als Akteur im politischen Feld nicht. Das ist noch ein bisschen schade. Und dann sind noch so zwei, drei technische Sachen gewesen, die ich auch gerne dringend habe, die auch ausgefallen sind. Also man muss mal sehen, wenn es jetzt eine Fortsetzung gibt, was man noch rein kriegt.
Je nachdem, wie das Projekt jetzt ankommt.
Ja, je nachdem, wie das Feedback jetzt ist, ob es gut weggeht oder nicht.
Gut, das Buch kann man schon bestellen? Kann man schon bestellen. Wir haben einen Link bei uns.
Bei Amazon und bei Transcop beim Verlag direkt.
Kost? 30 Euro. Okay, das ist ja fair. Na super. Sandro, dann sage ich mal vielen Dank für das Gespräch und den Überblick. Ich habe das Buch nicht gelesen und kann jetzt natürlich sagen, ich kann das alle nur empfehlen, wird das auf dem Kongress?
Gibt es auf dem Kongress, ja. Bei Patelun im Buchstand wird es ein paar Exemplare sein.
Na super. Dann nochmal vielen Dank. Und das war es bei Chaosradio Express. Heute mal so ein ganz anderer Blickwinkel zum Thema Überwachung. Dieses Buch als Anreiz, sich auch selber argumentativ auszurüsten. Ich merke immer, gerade in dieser ganzen Diskussion über Überwachung, Datenschutz, Privatsphäre und so weiter, da sind sehr viele Leute, die sehr engagiert sind, sehr motiviert sind da eigentlich auch, was dagegen zu tun. Und das dann immer so Sachen wie Demonstration und so weiter.
Viele haben halt nur so den subjektiven Eindruck, ich mag das nicht, ich will nicht überwacht werden.
Genau, da haben wir dann auch so konkrete Ängste. Es ist immer sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig, dass in dem Moment, wo man am Tisch sitzt, das auch wirklich mal rüberzubringen, warum das jetzt eigentlich das Ding ist. Ich selber, wenn ich so eine Diskussion führe, wie das jetzt auch bei uns im Gespräch rausgekommen ist, ich finde einfach auch diese Sache mit dem Missbrauchspotenzial finde ich eigentlich schon mal das größte Ding. Aber das ist auch relativ klar zu machen, dass ich meine, gerade in Deutschland, wir haben jetzt einfach mal in den letzten 100 Jahren ein bisschen zu viele Regime am Start gehabt, die einfach getan haben, was sie wollen und die einfach mal so das potenzielle Risiko von Missbrauch von Machtstrukturen einfach schon meiner Meinung nach so gut demonstriert haben, dass man da einfach keinerlei weitere Wagnisse eingehen sollte.
Na, das wäre jetzt blauäugig zu behaupten, man wäre jetzt im Wunder gehen.
Ja, und es herrscht aber so ein bisschen so diese Gedanken vor, so na ja, aber jetzt sind wir ja demokratisch und frei und pipapo und Wirtschaftswunderland und so weiter. Auf der anderen Seite eugt man jetzt schon wirklich mit großer Angst nach China, wenn man jetzt auf einmal sieht, dass da irgendwie dieses Viertel der Menschheit in einer Geschwindigkeit aufholt, wie man es vorher nie möglich erachtet hat. Gestern saßen sie alle noch in ihren Junken und jetzt haben sie auch Computer. Und dann kann sich da eben auch das wirtschaftliche Leben hier schnell verändern. Es gibt keine Garantie dafür, dass wir hier die nächsten 50 Jahre noch den gleichen Aufschwung und den gleichen Luxus fahren können. Also allein die, ich will jetzt nicht mit Klimakatastrophe anfangen, aber die natürlichen Ressourcen sind anders, der Ölpreis steigt hier und da. Es gibt viele Faktoren und es ist relativ leicht, kann man sich Szenarien auch ganz konkret vorstellen, die eben dann auch einen Einfluss auf die politische Diskussion haben. Und dann kommt es eben ganz schnell mit diesem, wir sind bedroht von was weiß ich, und jetzt brauchen wir diese und jene Maßnahme und so. Und dann ist halt schnell auch mal jemand gewählt, der eben nicht die philosophische Tiefe hat, unser aller Überleben sicherzustellen, sondern der sich einfach nur der Meinung ist, er müsste jetzt die maximal große Keule ausholen. Und irgendwann hat man es dann auch nur noch mit Machterhalt zu tun. Und das ist natürlich das Schlimmste, was passieren kann. Technische Systeme genauso. Deswegen gehen wir ja auch im Club gegen einen Wahlcomputer vor. Vieles von dem, was du jetzt so über die Auswirkungen und auch gerade diese Asymmetrie der Überwachung gesagt hast, das sehe ich zum Beispiel auch in der Diskussion ganz klar. Dass man also das wichtigste Kontrollsystem, nämlich die Nachvollziehbarkeit einer Wahl, durch den Einsatz von Technologie komplett aufgibt. So wie man sich eben dann auch seiner Privatsphäre berauben lässt durch Überwachung. Und das kann einfach alles nicht gut sein. So, das war jetzt ein langer Nachsatz. Aber ich denke, jetzt haben wir es. 97 Minuten. Es gibt viel zu reden über Überwachung. Also, nochmal danke Sandro. Und tschüss an alle Hörer. Viele Links zu dieser Sendung wie immer findet ihr auf blog.chaosradio.ccc.de. Wer von euch da noch nicht reingeschaut hat, das würde ich euch nochmal nahelegen. Im Blog suchen wir einfach ein bisschen mehr den Kontakt zu den Hörern. Ich weiß, es gibt viele. Nicht alle schicken Feedback. Aber uns wäre das sehr lieb, wenn ihr auch unsere Hintergrundprozesse ein wenig verfolgt, wenn euch das Angebot von Chaosradio Express und dem sonstigen Chaosradio Podcast-Network gefällt. Ja, in diesem Sinne sage ich Tschüss. Bis bald. Es wird in diesem Jahr noch ein paar Ausgaben geben. Aber wie es um eine Art ist, verrate ich noch nicht, worum es geht.